welcome to this meeting of Baba District
Council cabinet I'm councelor John Ward
leader of Baba District Council may I
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
remember to use the chat function only
to indicate that you wish to speak and
not to post comments or questions please
note that messages in the chat panel can
be viewed by people watching the live
broadcast I would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed to by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully
excluded I'll now ask the governance
officer to carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members this evening we have
several members of baber District
Council joining us also in attendance
are the chief executive the Strategic
director and the monitoring officer
thank you thanks CLA I'll now move to
the agenda item one apologies for
absence don't think we have any
we have no apologies
chair thank you item two to receive
Declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members are
there any to
declare Mr chairman can I declare um an
interest yes Council on RVC in the S bid
for long mford
right thank you any other declarations
yes thank you than you um yes I've I've
been alerted to the fact that I am known
to an executive officer of one of the
organizations submitting a bid for the
Bell View site and whilst this is not a
close personal relationship and
therefore does not constitute an
interest I think in the interest of
openness and
transparency it's pertinent to report
the acquaintance to the cabinet thank
you thank you coun
Ry if there are no other DEC ations we
will then move on to item three of the
agenda which is paper BCA 2037
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the B cabinet held on the 4th
of February
2021 um these are quite lengthy minutes
so about 16 pages so I won't go through
each page individually but I will ask if
members have any questions or comments
on on those minutes please indicate with
your hands if if that's the
case
councelor
Busby thank you chair item
65.6 I think he's on page 11 I think
page 11 let me have a
look um the corporate manager finance
and
commissioning advised that more details
on depreciation would be provided
outside of the meeting I don't think
I've had that yet
so if I could just chase that
up okay thank you thank you we will do
yes any other questions or comments on
the
minutes in which case then um may I have
a proposal
please thank you chairman I'll propose
thank you castc and a
second Happ you second chair thank you
councelor
Parker okay then um we will then uh move
to the electronic vote please
CLA thank you chair members if I can ask
you to go to the plus sign in the top
right hand corner of your modgv
app and select attendance and
voting the vote for this item is now
showing in blue as in
progress councelor Ary please can I take
your
vote yes that's four thank you chair
that's unanimous seven votes
for thank you CLA
right next is item four to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
nonone receiv received chair item five
questions by counselors non received
chair thank you item six matters
referred by the overviewing scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
I'll now invite councilor mcro chair of
the overviewing scrutiny committee to
introduce his
report councilor mcro thank you chair
and good evening members uh you have
before you two recommendations uh
arising out of the overview and scrutiny
committee's review of local citizens
advice uh as an appendix you have the
minutes of that meeting and I think the
minute speaks for itself two points I
think should be drawn out of those
minutes the first being that citizens
ADV viice despite the year of covid-19
that we've had have managed to keep
going and have managed to provide good
advice that very much Accords with our
own values and purposes and secondly
that the three-year rolling funding
Arrangement that we have had in place
this last year has been invaluable uh to
provide them with security uh for their
future planning the recommendations
before you um I would particularly draw
your attention to the second one
although we commend the work in the
first the second one re reaffirms uh and
reiterates the intention that the annual
rolling review three-year rolling should
be subject to indexation now due to
covid-19 it wasn't possible to prepare
uh a recommendation in time for this to
feed into the budgetary process but I
raised this at last month's cabinet
meeting um the committee have confirmed
that that is their View and I believe
that speaking to the assistant um
director uh concerning the matter Tom
Barker that I believe that an approach
to funding may be able to include that
within this year's final budget
arrangements or some other way uh that's
all I can really tell you thank you I'm
happy to take any questions you
have right thank you councilor mcro um I
have councilor Osborne uh you have a
question thank you Mr chairman no I
don't have a question um after uh
scrutinies recommendation coming forward
I think it prudent to declare a
non-pecuniary interest in the fact that
I'm a trustee on the citizens advice but
no questions thank you councilor mcro
okay thank you for that um any other
questions from anyone um the only
comment I'd wish to make um council mcco
is is concerning that um
indexation
um I think um from a council's
perspective we we'd like to look at that
as part of the wider grants review
across all of the organizations that we
we fund rather than just um focusing on
on the citizens advice Bureau so um
it'll be picked up under that process
that that was understood uh I only
mention it because of course it was a
specific recommendation from the
previous year and this cabinet did
charge us with carrying out the annual
review so we wish to be uh consistent in
our approach and we believe that in fact
it's in the interests of the council as
well as the communities thank you very
much okay thank
you right um I think that's that's it
for that we don't vote on on that item
um so we'll now move on to item seven
the forthcoming decisions list um
members of the cabinet you've you've all
had a chance to to look at that um does
anyone have any questions on that uh
it's it's not as uh heavy as as the past
few months um we are entering the or
will be entering the moratorium period
next month in the run up to the county
and police and crime commissioner
elections but um are there any questions
on the forthcoming decisions
list in which case then um we'll move on
to the next item on the
agenda which is
item8 paper BCA 2039 general fund
Financial monitoring for 2020 to 2021
quarter
3 so I'm pleased to present report BCA
2039 to Cabinet the general fund quarter
3 Financial monitoring for this current
year covering the revenue and Capital
financial performance for the period
October to December
2020 this is our third look at the
general fund compared with the budget
and it incorporates the up-to-date
impact of covid-19 on the council's
finances we continue to Monitor and
update the impact of the unplanned costs
and loss of income due to covid and the
government financial support we have and
are still receiving as I mentioned at
Council last month the three-year
comprehensive spending review has been
delayed again and a one-year review was
published in November focusing on
priority on prioritizing the response to
covid the government has provided us
with a lot of support and as a result of
this together with our usual careful
management we have been able to protect
the council's finances from what could
have been a devastating
situation the uncertainty that we had
been living with is now being resolved
with further support into the next
financial year without tempting fate too
much we can now see a norm more normal
future very soon with a remote road map
out of lockdown and the amazing vaccine
roll out both providing
optimism the financial impact of covid
the additional costs income reduction
impact on council tax and business rates
offset with the financial support we
have received to date is presented in
section five our additional land plan
costs have increased from just under1
million pound in quarter 2 to just under
1.4 million pound and there will be a
reduction in income from our sales fees
and charges of about1 1.1 million which
is slightly less than the quarter to
forecast The Collection fund deficit
next year is expected to be about
£230,000
the total impact is now expected to be2
2.64 4
million the table in paragraph 5.8 lists
all the co Government funding we have
received to date and this is currently a
total of 1.82 two million not including
the £47,000 that has been transferred to
the
HRA this is 69% of the total costs and
losses leaving us with a gap of
£22,000 to
fund as described in paragraph 5.9 the
scheme sees the government covering 75%
of irrecoverable sales fees and charges
losses above 5% of planned income will
be extended until the end of June also
the collection fund deficit can be
spread over the next three years there
is also good news regarding abicor Le
Leisure 170,000 compensation has been
awarded from the national Leisure Relief
Fund for the Baba Leisure centers and it
looks like they will be able B to open
next month having said all this I am
pleased to report that the revenue
account position for the council remains
positive and has improved considerably
since quarter 2 the key variances
compared with budget are set out in
paragraph
6.6 some notable items and changes
compared with quarter 2 other than the
covid losses are as follows we're now
Force casting a positive variance of
220,000 for CCO a further Improvement on
quarter 2 we are forecasting an adverse
variance of £5,000 due to loss of income
from our other commercial
properties loss of car park income is
expected to result in an adverse
variance of £87,000
significantly worse than quarter 2 but
negated by an improved adverse variance
of uh 71,000 due to a reduction in
income from the Waste
Services there is an adverse variance of
£92,000 for planning compris of a loss
of income of £
291,000 offset by Savings of £99,000 for
other items this is a significant
Improvement on the ctit DU position due
to favor favorable variances for appeals
expenditure and sill Administration
charges we are forecasting an unpend of
£70,000 on training and there is an
expected £450,000 favorable variance for
our 5% vacancy management Factor the
same as in quarter
2 a favorable variance of 237,000 is now
expected for business rates which is an
improvement of £ 799,000
on the figure at quarter two this is the
principal contribution to the improved
position this quarter it follows
completion of the council's business
rates forecast for 2021 to 22 and the
changes required by central government
for the treatment of the retail
hospitality and Leisure relief as at
quarter 2 in addition to the government
funding we are also increasing 400 uh we
are also including £ 456,000 of other
funding and support and that is housing
benefit income to cover homelessness
costs track and Trace funding community
UND spend and the shared Revenue
partnership absorbing additional
costs as a result of all this we are
anticipating a surplus of1 1. 388
million for the year compared with
$728,000 a quarter two whilst this is
good news and testament to The Prudent
management of our finances by the
section one one officers team there are
risks associ associated with the final
quarter forecast and I do still want to
wait for the outturn before celebrating
too much
we received
.807 million of sill income in the first
three quarters of this year which is up
from uh the same period last
year apart from the 5% Administration
charge this will be be transferred to
the E marked Reserve paragraph 6.11 of
the report summarizes the current
predicted movements in the
transformation fund with a forecast
balance of
$837,000 at the end of the year at this
stage we're not showing a transfer of
any of the budget surplus to this as it
is likely along with other Reserve
movements to change the transformation
fund details are provided in appendix B
but please note that a revised appendix
B is in the supplement pack there is a
problem with the totals totals line in
the
original appendix a shows how we're
spending the 100% business rates
retention
pilot 67 uh 670,000 is still unspent of
which 28,000 is as yet
unallocated appendix C sets out our
general fund aark Reserves including
forecast transfers these have increased
slightly since quarter 2 and are now
just under 5.5 million excluding
sill looking at the medium term as I
reported to council the overall budget
gap for the three years from 2022 to 23
amounts of accumulative deficit of 1.7
million on top of this the impact of co
could be felt for several years we know
that new homes bonus has been phased out
and consultation on its replacement is
underway however the council's main
strategic Financial aim remains to
become self- financing and not reliant
on Government funding use of reserves
will be a last resort as it doesn't
represent a sustainable
strategy finally our general fund
Capital program is detailed in appendix
D and paragraphs 614 to
616 Co has resulted in the number of
delays and increased
costs excluding cifco we have 22 20.2
million revised capital expenditure
program this year with an anticipated
spend of 4.2 million
now there is an error in appendix D and
unfortunately I only spotted it a couple
of days ago the the former Bell View
Hotel money has been entered as a carry
forward in error which means that two of
the numbers in paragraph 615 are
incorrect so in actual fact um 615
should read that we have carry forwards
of £ 11.9 million leaving an underspend
this year of 4.1 million which is mostly
due to the canc cancellation of that
bellw hotel project
so the numbers are are more or less
right but they're just in in the wrong
places the main variances relating to
the Carri forwards and UND spense Al
listed in paragraph 616 and appendix D
I'd like to thank our finance team for
all their hard work keeping up with a
changing position this year whilst
working on the budget for next year over
the past couple of months or so March
and April are typically easier months
for them and so hopefully they can enjoy
some relaxation time before opening up
for questions and debate I'd first like
to move the recommendation in section
three of the report that the council's
financial position for the general fund
at the end of quarter 3 be noted and may
I have a second please I'm happy to
second that Mr chairman it's councelor
Jan Osborne yes thank you councelor
Osborne thank
you right okay members of the cabinet um
uh we'll now go through questions um
firstly councelor arthy do you have any
questions I I have just one um chairman
thank you and it's about
CCO and I think it's on page 37 and it's
the fa the variable sorry the favorable
variant um of some £400,000
which I think is reduced borrowing costs
um from the public works loans board
compared to our budgeted assumptions in
February
2020 is is that
right uh yes we we we're taking out more
short-term borrowing um because of the
lower interest rates there and and um
less from the public works loan board
and I think that's been the Principal
contribution to to that favorable
variance but um if if I may I will ask
um Melissa if she's available to confirm
that y thank you chair yeah you're
absolutely spot on with that answer is
the the short-term borrowing that we're
we're taking rather than from The
public's Works loans board so yeah
thanks so could I just follow that up
with our budget assumptions this
year that's the question how does that
compare um in terms of the the 2022 to
23 uh sorry 21 to 22
budget yeah no what I meant was the
assumptions with regard to the the rate
at the Public Works loans board because
obviously last February we um we
anticipated that our borrowing would be
a certain figure but we were fortunate
if you like um that short-term borrowing
costs were less um now that was less
than the Assumption we made in February
2020 um so I just wondered what
assumptions we made um this year because
obviously we could have the opposite
situation this year couldn't
we Melissa do you have you want me to
come in there yeah absolutely yeah um we
have actually done the same thing so
we've assumed that we will take uh
Public Works Lo board borrowing for the
next financial year so if we do continue
for a time during 2122 at Short Term
there will be a benefit but we are
looking at our long-term borrowing with
our treasury advisors to see when is the
time a good time to switch into that
long-term borrowing so at some point
during 2122 we will shift over to that
pwb borrowing um but we we've prudently
budgeted for the higher borrowing cost
if that makes sense it does make sense
yeah thank
you uh councilor Busby and yeah actually
following up on that yes um I don't
think we'll be doing any more borrowing
on cifco because we hope to be fully
invested by the end of this year and uh
we won't be allowed to use Public Works
loan board money anyway because they are
very anti anti anti the this kind of
investment um I've got a question on
page seven do with the Leisure contracts
is the detailed
variances I mean you may be able to
answer it with having to look at it uh I
was very pleased to hear about the
170,000 uh Grant or donation from the
government but I'm still surprised to
see that we've got a favorable
variance and I'm just finding the show a
favorable variance of
38,000 CH did you want me to come yes
please as a result of the um the free
swims um that's not happening so we're
not making that 38,000 contribution to
the Leisure Center for the free swims
that we would were budgeting to do but
do we did we not make a grant haven't we
not been um
subsidizing Abby Croft did that not go
through there yes we have y yeah and
that's 38,000 favorable after that yes
yeah so yeah so we're showing the um the
actual pressure of that um elsewhere in
the report um I'm just finding the right
place just bear with me a
second I think I may have to come back
to you on that one counselor BOS because
I don't want to waste people's time
while I try and look for the the answer
is that okay if I come back to thank you
and then chair I've just got one other
point um page 17 which appendix
B
ending spe yeah go on hang on let me get
to
it it's quite a complicated
document um it would be a lot simpler if
it was just related to Baba could we
have a have that appendix in future just
Baba figures rather than a mixture of
the
two I don't see why not it it's always
been presented like this but yeah I know
it's always been confusing
yeah fair enough yeah it's just there's
um uh in terms of the expenditure on
various items that there are a number of
items that are funded from both the um
transformation fund and the growth and
efficiency fund of
mids right but I still don't see why you
can't drop the mids items out we don't
share funds do we no but um we it's
confusing when you look at the last kind
of columns where it shows total spend
and variance well that's not our
necessarily our variance that could
be okay well we look at that it would be
clearer and if it was just babber okay
we'll look at that in future thank you
okay councilor
Davis nothing for me thank you
okay right um councilor
halt any questions from you no fine
thank you John councilor
mvi no thank you Mr chairman Council
Osborne yeah thank you Mr chairman um
that's the problem we coming near the
end the question has been asked I was
going to ask the one on CCO that councel
arthy has asked the first question on
CCO um but taking in the taking into
reference um what council Busby has just
said alluded to about the Abby Croft and
that variance has that been Tak taken
into consideration with the 2122 budget
because if I recall members very very
reluctantly stopped the free swims for
2122 and I'm wondering now if we
actually needed to do that so was was
that taken into consideration in the
overall
budget well the um we we have in in the
21 to 22 budget we have um taken account
that there are no free swims for for the
forthcoming Financial year yeah but have
we Tak that variance into consideration
in the the variance that's reported here
for this current year is um the fact
that those swims didn't take place
because um we we've been in lockdown and
and Leisure centers haven't been
available um and indeed in Hadley the
new pool hasn't been
available okay and you know as you
recall we very reluctantly stopped I
know we did yeah to do it and if there's
a way that we can bring them back in
again you know obviously we'd need to
look at that in future
months and and then certainly when we
come to look at the 22 to 23 budget um
we we can um take into account um what
has happened uh this current year and in
in the forth Poss reintroducing yeah and
and um we we did State at the time of
the budget debate last month at Council
that um it was likely to be only a
one-year suspension and that we do want
to u to um to to reintroduce it
councelor Davis be great thank you
yeah did you want to say something on
that yeah um I think um to to reassure
councilor Osborne We you're absolutely
right we were very reluctant but we also
took the decision that this year um it
it's going to be very difficult to
actually implement the free swims anyway
because we don't know what sort of
restrictions are ahead of us we don't
know um how swimming pools will be able
to come back and free swims obviously uh
fall under under under the whole um
guidelines that the Leisure centers will
have to operate so you know like you
I've accepted it for one year but
certainly will'll be you know batting
away in that corner for the following
year to make sure that they are
reintroduced you know given that nothing
uh Dreadful happens in the
meantime yeah thanks councelor so
finally on questions councelor Parker do
you have any questions uh no thank you
chair everything's good thank you do any
other members of uh B present have any
questions at this stage on the general
fund budget councelor
Maybury thank you very much Mr chairman
um first of all I not in the cabinet but
because the citizens
advice was mentioned I will declare that
I am a director in case somebody
comments that I was present but I didn't
speak on that
subject um I have two
questions uh would it be possible for
someone please to explain or clarify the
losses on planning do you want would you
like the questions together or just that
one uh take them together thank you yeah
okay um the second question is on the
free swimming um and I have spoken to
Tom Barker the officer about
this I very much appreciate the free
swims for children but I did didn't feel
that the process actually targeted those
that we needed to Target which was the
more vulnerable families so I hope that
that will be taken into account um if Mr
bark was here perhaps he can comment
what's the question exactly well the
question is will you be um altering the
process for swi free swims to make sure
that the vulnerable families the more
vulnerable families um have the the
benefit of them um free free swims are
Universal for under 17s and um and when
they get reintroduced um that will will
still be the case if I can just differ
with you um if they're under a certain
age the adults have to attend which
means that the adults have to pay and if
they are vulnerable family on a strapped
income then they do not benefit well
we'll have to take that outside of um
this and that that would
be change that um we would need to
consider at a later date thank you very
much okay um so your your planning
question though um I'm just trying to
pull up the relevant information in
front of me here at the moment which is
taking a bit of time
to to appear on my
screen sorry about the delay counselor
okay
where is
that sorry I'm just trying to find the
the actual page I might have to uh
revert
to Melissa on this one I don't seem to
have that particular information in
front of me at the moment 38
yeah trying to get to
that yeah okay so uh you're talking
about the income shortfall of
291,000 yes
please um well that's going to be
presumably due to um planning fee uh
income being significantly reduced and
and preapp advice income but Melissa can
you confirm that yeah you're absolutely
right there chair it is yeah as a result
of a a decline in the development um as
the pandemic hit obviously things
stopped so planning applications dropped
off so naturally our income dropped as
well yeah thank you thank you okay
councilor May any other uh councilors
present um wish to ask a question if not
um we will move
into uh cabinet debate um which we can
do now um councilor arthy do you wish to
open the
debate um well not exactly chairman but
I think that councelor Osborne made a
good point um and of course it it will
be a little while before we have the
full year outturn figures um and I
noticed that Melissa used words like
cautious and prudent um but it it does
seem that maybe we were a little bit
overly cautious and overly prudent um in
that um there were some cuts that we
made for next year's budget um or this
coming Year's budget which may actually
prove to to be unnecessary um but I
guess we'll have to wait until the until
the final um outturn figures for the
year yeah the trouble is we have to make
these decisions um fairly early on if if
you remember we were looking at them in
October and November um and um at that
stage we we hadn't even even seen the
quarter 2 uh monitoring report let alone
um quarter three and um and obviously
the outturn will will
um uh will give us a different picture
again so um but you're right I mean
these are these
are decisions we have to make and and
sometimes uh they have been too cautious
but um it's better to ear on the side of
caution than than not yeah no I
absolutely accept that and it's probably
over six months ago that we started
looking at um budget figures and then we
were much more pessimistic um about the
likely outturn than we are now so yeah I
accept that thanks Council
Busby do you have any comments well only
just to follow up with that uh it might
look very favorable for this year but
we're still facing a a problematic
medium-term
financial situation so let's not Chuck
start chucking our money away
unnecessarily although I think it could
be a decision that we review Midway
through the year yeah when we'll know
what CO's happening and and the poll's
been open Etc but I haven't got anything
else thank you thank you councilor
Davis nothing from me thank you
councelor
halt no nothing for me Council
MVC no nothing from me that hasn't
already been said Thank You councelor
Osborne no nothing from me thank you Mr
chairman and uh finally Council Parker
uh nothing for me chair thank you okay
then um well thanks for that uh I'll now
ask the governance officer to conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair members if you go
into your modgv
app the vote for this item is now in
progress
thank you Council Ary can I take your
vote
please yes of course uh it's for thank
you thank you chair that's eight votes
for that's
unanimous thanks
CLA okay right um so now moving on to
item nine paper BCA 2040 the housing
revenue account Financial monitoring
2020 to
2021 quarter
3 so I'm pleased to now to introduce
report BCA 2040 to Cabinet the housing
revenue account quarter 3 Financial
monitoring for this current year the
report covers the HRA Revenue budget and
the HRA Capital program for the period
October to December 2020 and this is our
third look at how we think our H is
looking for the full year compared with
the budget and as with the general fund
it incorporates the up-to-date impact of
covid-19 on the council's HRA
finances Co is having a financial impact
on the council's housing revenue account
rent levels are at a risk repairs and
maintenance was reduced emergency
repairs for existing tenants only and to
complete void work in order to support
the accommodation of the homeless and
rough sleepers new build and repairs and
maintenance did restart after the Autumn
lockdown but then had to stop again
service levels will still take time to
recover C and there will will be a
backlog of work there will be additional
costs to recommence new build work
safely as the year progresses this
financial impact will be forecast with
more certainty but the current impact
assessment is presented in section five
of the report the additional costs due
to co are mainly the need for PPE which
is uh amounting to £47,000 and which has
been transferred from the government
support grants
money we're still seeing a minimal
impact on rent levels and rents are
expected to be reclaimed eventually
rather than written off but this will
extend beyond the current Financial year
as a result of the extension to the
Furlow scheme we are now not expecting
any reduction to income levels in this
current year actually and the impact is
likely therefore to be in in the
forthcoming Financial
year the revenue position is detailed in
paragraphs 63 to 611 as always the
financial position of the H should be
viewed in the context of the updated
30-year business plan the budget set in
February last year showed a forecast
Surplus position for 2020 to 21 of 30
334,000
we are now forecasting a surplus of 2.8
million which represents a favorable
variance of just under £2.5 million
against budget and a further substantial
Improvement since quarter 2 as a result
of no longer having to make a provision
for loss of rental income the table in
paragraph 63 lists the main items the
bud in the budget and a detailed
breakdown of the variances is provided
in paragraphs 66 to 610
every item is showing a favorable
variance which with many expenditure
underspend due to covid much of which
will be deferred to next year the
principal difference from Quarter Two is
as I have already mentioned the greatly
improved position regarding dwelling
rents which is now showing a favorable
variance of £188,000
all this means that our H balances are
forecast to be 16.75 7 million as
detailed in paragraph
611 Co has has had a huge impact on our
Capital program this year and on the
normally difficult task of accurately
assessing the level of payments for
complex Capital schemes the capital
program is itemized in appendix a and
further detail provided in paragraphs
612 to 615 of the report actual Capital
expenditures for April to December 2020
total 7.1 million against a budget of
28.8 million pounds although they have
although they have restarted projects
have fallen behind schedule and their
budgets will be carried forward to meet
expenditure incurred next year we are
expecting the full year Capital spend to
be £17.59 2 million pounds with 10.83 3
million pounds being carried
forward before opening up for questions
and debate I'd first like to move the
recommendation section three of the
report the council's financial position
for the HRA at the end of quarter 3 be
noted and may I have a second for this
please
second councilor Jan o borne I'm happy
to say second
okay thank thank you right uh so firstly
questions councelor
arthy yeah I have got one and I'm I'm
sorry to just pull this out of nowhere
um but I'm just thinking back to um a
project that we authorized which was the
assessment of the council's garage sites
for um potential Redevelopment um either
for housing or possibly for um parking
um without garages and and I think we
spoke about things like EV charger
points and we spoke about solar car
ports as well which we're um looking at
in the car park and I'm I'm sorry that
I've just sort of come up with this now
but it doesn't feature here as being
suspended or anything but I seem to
recall that about nine months ago we
were told that work on that would be
delayed resource that um that work was
but I I just wondered if if there was
any update on that I think Council
Osborne can provide an answer to that
can you can you please yeah thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your question uh
Council arthy um yeah it it was put on
the back burner with with the covid
because the resources were put into
other places for obvious reasons um no
it's still it's come to the four again
now very much so I had a meeting with uh
Lee cell only last week and a briefing
note is being put together we're just
waiting for some um details to come from
the asset team and then we'll be
circulating a briefing note to all
members on an update on garage sites
because there has been quite a few
questions on this at full Council and I
think at the last cabinet meeting as
well so there's a lot of interest from
members in in the where we are
progressing with the garage sites so uh
to answer your question there will be a
briefing Note coming forward um that
will outline where we are what we plan
to do and some timelines to to it as
well does that answer your question Mr
arthy councelor
arthy it does yeah thank you very much
thank you thank you Council Busby do you
have a
question no thank you councilor
Davis no thank you can you hear me
Council
Hal yeah just one thing um on the
backlog of repairs um
are we forecasting that we will be able
to catch up within the next 12 months
and if so will extra resources and
funding need to be provided to catch up
and M maintain the uh standard of our
housing councilor Osborne would you like
to answer or should I ask um gav well I
I can come in initially and then perhaps
um Gavin can come in I'm sure he have
some more details on it on us we're
actually currently on um 17 days days uh
for void so that's not bad considering
that um we've had to we've had the covid
in place the actual voids we're actually
managing to get in to do those because
there's no risk obviously because the
properties are empty so we're managing
to keep a track keep track of those what
we can't do at the moment and haven't
been able to do for for nearly 12 months
is non-emergency repairs so that's where
the backlog is going to be I don't think
we'll necessarily have to put more
resources into it I know that Gavin and
his team will be looking at it very
closely to see how we can manage that
and already plans are in place on to
make sure that we catch up when we're
able to do so but I don't know if Gavin
you've got any more details on
that thank you um councelor Osborne and
uh thank you uh uh Council uh Ward um
just in uh response to the the question
um yes inevitably um after uh so many uh
delayed periods of time when repairs
haven't been carried out because um
let's recall that actually this is the
third lockdown and um the the service
has been stop start for for for nearly a
whole year now um we are intending to uh
hope that uh we can start to offer a
Full Repair Service uh later in March
and this will enable um all residents to
uh book and be allocated uh work uh as
appropriate uh we are conscious that
actually there will create uh some
backlog uh and clearly the way of
managing that will be to prioritize the
work um in accordance with uh uh with
safety uh with with urgency uh based on
the type of work and that's what we've
been doing throughout in in regards to
those emergency jobs um I think it's
probably important to note that um in
years uh prior to to to this year I I
recall sitting here in front of you as a
Cabinet uh talking at budget monitoring
about significant um adverse variances I
think it's really positive if and shows
the trajectory um and the support that
cabinets gave to Building Services um
only um a few months ago in terms of
investing um in that service um and what
I'm pleased to say is that that
investment is is reaping rewards so uh
we now have uh a new corporate
managering post uh we have new staff uh
joining uh to to replace existing staff
members um and actually in terms of uh
the budget setting process that you as
members of recently approved actually
we're looking at delivering the service
in a different way so for example less
Reliance on
subcontractors um and actually
increasing our own Workforce to carry
out certain types of work which not only
will save uh the council um and and the
H additional sums uh but it expects us
to be able to deliver a a higher uh
greater level of service because of us
being able to manage that um and then
I'll just turn my attention to examples
such as the mobile technology um and the
solution that we developed and
implemented during the second uh covid
lockdown which actually gives our staff
the uh opportunity to uh access a
tenant's mobile phone um look at the the
repair uh and make decisive decisions as
to what needs to be done uh from um
obviously uh uh remotely from from
officers so I think with Solutions such
as those you can see and and and it
demonstrates actually we'll be able to
deliver the service in in a far more
effective and efficient way going
forward thank you
g thanks um so moving on councelor mvi
do you have any
questions no thank you chair councelor
Osborne no no thank you Mr chairman
councel Parker no thank you
chair right okay do any other members of
the bber council present have any
questions on the HR
report in which case we'll move on to
the cabinet debate section so um
councelor Ary would you like to open the
debate do you have anything you wish to
comment on thank you chairman no I've
got I've got no additional comments
thank you councilor Busby no nothing
from me either thanks councelor Davis
nothing from me thank you Council halt
just one thing um the right to buy
receipts that we've disc discussed
previously um we have a three-year
period to spend them um are we on top of
that and making sure that we don't not
have to return those to government
absolutely very much so and I know
Council Osborne will probably want to
say something about this and I don't
want to steal her Thunder but um we've
got very good news on on that um so
counc Osan did you want to answer
that yes thank you you could have stolen
my thunder I really wouldn't have minded
um yeah a few months ago it was it was
it wasn't looking too good it looked as
though unfortunately we were going to
have to give the government back some
money but the team have worked so hard
even with the covid uh challenge they've
worked really hard and now we forecast
an overspend of over of nearly 2 million
pounds which is a great it might sound
awful and overspend but in actual fact
that is really brilliant news so well
done to the team for all that hard work
that they've done to bring us to this to
this position it is much more reassuring
than it was uh six or seven months ago
no spend means we have more Council
houses which um yeah which is excellent
yeah okay uh thanks for that councelor
Osborne um right councilor
mvi nothing to say that hasn't been said
already thank you very much and Council
Osborne I guess you haven't got anything
more to say have you or or have you no
thank you very much Mr chairman I think
I've said enough councelor
Parker no thank you chair that's good
thank you okay well that's that's great
everyone Thanks so I'll now ask the
government officer to conduct the
electronic vote
please thank you chair members if you
can go into your modov app the vote is
now in progress and should show in
blue
councilor Ary can I take your vote
please mine's mine's are four thank you
very much thank you chair that's eight
votes for that is
unanimous great thanks CLA
you okay then so moving on the next item
is item 10 paper BCA 2041 quarter 3
Performance present presentation and
I'll now invite the cabinet member for
customers digital transformation and
Improvement to provide an introduction
to this item which is for noting only so
councelor Parker over to you yeah thank
you chair precisely that so um this item
is a presentation of performance across
the whole Council uh covering uh Q3 as
you quite rightly say there's no
recommendation for the report instead
members are asked only to note the
information contained within the
presentation uh in order to reflect and
comment on progress made against the key
priorities within the corporate plan uh
accordingly I'd like to invite the
assistant director for customer Sarah
wilock to take us through the report uh
and of course we'll be happy to answer
any questions thereafter thank you
chair thank you councelor Parker and
good evening councilors I'd like to
introduce to you our quarter 3
Performance presentation uh covering the
period October through to December
2020 you'll see that the presentation
follows our new style which was
introduced at the beginning of this
financial year and is focused as
councilor Parker has said on our six key
pre priorities from the corporate plan
as well as our health of the
organization which illustrates key
themes which ensure the council is
working efficiently and effectively
taking it in entirety the report seeks
to provide that high level Assurance
highlighting key performance measures
some progress against objectives and a
look forward to planned activity in the
next quarter
as is usual I don't intend to run
through the entirety of both
presentations because there's an awful
lot of detail included in there I would
however just like to highlight a couple
of themes the first of which is our
desire to continuously improve and
review the format and content of the
presentation with every iteration I
think we are making some progress both
in terms of content as well as
engagement with colleagues across the
councils but that's not to say that I
think that there is still more that we
can do to make some improvements and we
will be working with colleagues to focus
on outcomes rather than purely narrative
on what we have been doing we also need
to maintain a focus on quality rather
than quantity and if you recall one of
the aims when we first developed the new
style format was to try and keep it
concise and short and snappy and to move
away from the pages and pages of content
that we expected people to digest
certainly in this quarter I can see that
we've added a few to the page C
and for the final quarter I'll be
working with teams to try and redress
this we also want to continue to try and
bring these presentations to life with
much more interactive content and
individual case
studies a second theme that I'd like to
draw your attention to is obviously the
impact that the pandemic has had during
quarter 3 and continues to have on us
resulting in a heavy focus on covid
response work unsurprisingly our
attentions are diverted which means some
objectives and activity has slowed or
pause but we have tried to reflect in
the presentations where this has
happened explicitly and equally
explained what activity has taken place
instead you'll see this uh most notably
in the well-being objective for
example so that's all I wanted to uh
conclude with happy to hand back the
chair for any comments and questions
thank
you thank you Sarah that's that's great
so um cabinet members do you have any
questions firstly councilor
arthy uh thank you chairman no it's not
actually a question so I'll save it
until um until the debate it's well
actually um we won't be having a
separate debate section because it's not
um an item for voting on so um questions
and comments or okay well I'd just like
to highlight um a couple of the figures
which are on page 18 I think um which um
are are of concern to us and they're of
concern to the sofic waste partnership
as well and hello
sorry yeah um and um that's as I say on
page 18 and it's the
contamination um at the murf is quite a
concerning figure that's been slowly
Rising there are several reasons for
that um the quality of material going
through the murf now has to be even
higher than it was before um in order to
meet the demands of the market so that
is is something that causes an increase
in in the actual figure for
contamination but we have had quite a
worrying amount of um non-recyclable
stuff put in the blue bins um and that's
the reason for the recent um campaign to
try and improve the quality of
recyclables the other um is an effect
that we thought in the early um days of
of the covid impact we thought wasn't
happening um but now it appears it is
um and it's probably to do with the the
closure and then the um the changes to
the arrangements for household waste and
recycling centers but it's the figure of
144 incidents of fly tipping um which is
more than double the same period um
previously so you know those are a
couple of um kind kind of worrying
figures um that we're hoping to do
something
about
yeah thank you councilor Ary they are
worrying particularly is that um
contamination is now up to 20% almost um
that the fly tipping numbers
um you're right are worrying but our
team is is very responsive to
notification of fly tipping and has done
an excellent job to uh to respond to
that increased problem in terms of
clearing things
up um right so councelor Busby do you
have any questions or comments well only
one that I think made before which is
that it's a it's a good report and I
think we ought to have a wider audience
for it maybe we could uh each month send
out one of the uh objectives so each
objective would be dealt with twice in a
year perhaps but I think the report does
need sharpening up a bit first I think
Sarah know that thank you councelor
Davis no um I I agree with um councilor
Busby there about what a good report it
is and how concise it is and um I I I
can't let the opportunity go by without
praising um you know my portfolio team
the community's team um who have taken
on board uh all the strategies that we
need to progress and um and our
performance as you will see has improved
and that's despite really really
challenging times I know all officers
have had a very difficult time but I
think the communi team need a special
mention for the work they've done in in
health and well-being and the community
ities grants and the whole wide range I
could go on forever but no so for me
it's a huge thank you to to all my team
to Tom and Vicki and everyone else thank
you okay thank you counselor councelor
halt yeah just following on from
councelor um Davis really I'd just like
to say huge thank you to the economic
team who've been paying out all the co
grants I mean you can see in the figures
in the report that there are large
figures and there's a lot of businesses
that have been helped and you and
continue to be helped and um this vital
work shouldn't be uh unrecognized so
thank you to all of them thank you
councilor
Mai thank you very much chairman um yes
I'd like um all members currently
present to note the objectives and the
achievements of the environment team
moving over to hydro um hydrotreated
vegetable oil for our vehicle Fleet um
the increase
our not attack but our progress on
biodiversity and moving that forward um
we've we've worked very
hard to achieve a lot on
the environment front and I can report
that babber is quite respected
nationally for being so advanced in
numerous areas not just focusing on one
we're tweaking everything we can to
slowly um achieve our objective of zero
carbon and a net uh a biodiversity net
gain thank you councelor
Osborne yes thank you Mr chairman um
yeah I would yeah I again I would like
to say thank you to the housing team for
obviously the the challenges that
they've had to meet during this last 12
months has been absolutely colossal and
they they've dealt with it in an amazing
amazing way so big thank you to them I
would like to point something out on
page 22 which is the headline
performance indicators it on the
affordable homes acquired our bill it
it's it says two which doesn't really
give a true picture I admit it does for
that particular quarter but what I would
like to bring to everybody's attention
is in April
2015 we had
3,441 homes in our housing stock as at
February and this includes those we've
completed on but not current currently
um occupied we now have
3,568 that's an increase
of7 that is an incredible amount and
that is given a home to those that most
need it so I I'm hoping that in the next
quarters coming forward it will show for
example the 45 that are coming through
in wenfield Road the 21 in Angel Court
nine in branam and shley the 28 wasley
gra and the eight in long mford so um
not uh Lavenham sorry not long mford
laam so it that figure is is quite
misleading that to it really is a you
know a great number that we've achieved
in that particular period of time so I'm
just hoping that that figure looks a
little bit more looks bit better um
gives a more indication of the success
story of this because it is a success
story um in the quarters to follow
through thank you Mr chairman yeah thank
you Council osor and it's not just what
we have um done in that period since
2015 and the pipeline that we've got
coming up um but it's also the Ambitions
for the next few years as well uh which
are significant and and we'll see
significant increases in our housing
stock councelor Parker do you have any
questions or comments um well just to
follow up on something something that um
councelor bosby said I mean he he raises
a very good point about making these
reports even more accessible and I have
fed that back already um to Sarah um and
and it's something that is absolutely
we're going to aim to do that and um and
and as soon as possible as well so um
thank you very much Council bosby thank
you and i' just like to pick up on uh
one or two points that um my fellow
cabinet members have made and that is
that the data here does show that um
everyone all of our officers and
um have been performing in the past year
brilliantly uh not just with their
existing and and day jobs but in the
response to covid which has had an
impact on those day jobs and also
provided them with a lot of extra work
so um I I think this this past year has
has been has shown babber well Baba mids
suffer because it's a shared officer uh
core um has shown that uh we we are two
very fortunate districts in in having
the the people we have working for us um
I'd now like to open it up to any other
members present I have two hands up
already councelor
Barrett um good evening everyone um
unfortunately I'm not going to uh uh
speak to thank every anyone because I I
I think actually what our job is more
about um uh doing even better and being
ambitious so um um I've got a question
about telephony
telefony um I hope that's this fits in
with this um this spot to the the agenda
um I've been contacted recently by um a
difficult about the difficulty of
getting to speak to someone in the
planning department um councelor arthy
know knows about this recent case um
during the lockdown I think it's been
difficult with people working from home
understandably um where the I don't
think there is a opportunity to forward
um voice the the um phones to another
another person
[Music]
sorry um is
there is there any is there any uh way
in which we can ensure that these
callers can get through to to an officer
um because I expect the lockdown is
going to continue for quite some some
weeks
away perhaps um perhaps thanks councelor
um Sarah are you able to um respond to
that yes thank you councelor ward and uh
councelor Barrett for your for your
question more than happy to take away
individual um details of of residents
who have had difficulties engaging
through through the telepan uh We've pre
presented some information on the report
that indicates that our our average
weight times are are below our um our
targets at the moment and I think have
been throughout the the pandemic and
certainly our abandonment rate so those
people that can't actually get through
to us is is again less than our Target
of of 10% um down at
7% but um and we have enabled technology
we've got our call center staff who are
able to work from home um and calls are
able to come through to them uh I think
if there's a particular issue in um a
service where it's then requiring some
back office expert help to support with
a more technical question that's
something that I'm more than happy to
take away and and look at if you've got
some individual details that you could
perhaps forward to me at some point I I
don't think it's call as coming through
to the main numbers that are advertised
I think it's where they the uh caller
has got got an officer's name they're
trying to call them they're probably
unavailable for a few minutes um or
perhaps on another call if they were in
the office I believe that the systems
would mean that that call would bounce
to another person within a a a ring ring
of callers I guess that can't happen at
home is that correct um as far as I'm
aware it can happen because our our
numbers are all sort of council Network
numbers they're not necessarily IND
individual home numbers that we're using
and when we moved across from Skype to
Microsoft teams for those areas that
required that kind of group set up so
that calls would bounce amongst them um
before someone would answer we did get
those set up so you know really happy to
take away those individual concerns
because that's not how how how our
systems should work and also our
colleagues across the organization are
aware of our customer service standards
which means that everybody should have
voicemails activated and set up on their
own numbers so that people can leave a
message if they're not available and a
requirement on our staff for that for
contact them back in a timely way so if
that's not happening more than happy to
take that on an individual basis I I
will forward you an email that I
received perhaps you can have a look
thank you very much we'll do thank
you thank you uh councilor
McCraw thank you chair
uh first of all uh this is more of an
observation than a question but there
will be a question at the end uh these
reports are becoming increasingly useful
uh where there are changes that uh are
adverse as we might say there are
usually explanations for them and I
think many of those owe something to the
effects of the last year but there is
one that slightly concerns me and I'd
like to ask Sarah if any explanation
could be provided for a dis
disappointing result in customer
feedback website feedback bar shows a
rating of 2.26 out of five that's I
would have said under the circumstances
under any circumstances could be
described as disappointing and is there
any possible explanation for
that thank you counselor oh councelor
Parker did you want to come back on that
or or
Sarah I'm quite happy to leave it to the
expert I I think I did have an
explanation but I'll leave it to the
expert that's
okay thank you Sarah thank you thank you
councelor mcgr for your for your
question um without any doubt 2.26 out
of five it is
disappointing um some of the reason
behind that is because of the nature of
the the requests or the statements that
are made within um the feedback so we
allow a free text space for people to to
pop their responses down and we do pass
back to Services um any any feedback
that we receive what we do find when
reviewing those is that sometimes the um
the comment will relate not to perhaps
the the user experience on the website
um but more about the a failure of the
service in particular so for example
they might put a negative comment if
they're having to register a Miss bin
for example so um we find that there's
often a correlation between the comments
and negative respond in relation to the
actual service that they're trying to to
um access and receive rather than
actually that their use of the website
as a whole so it may be related to
expectations and outcomes rather than
the actual service provided yeah and
that's not to say that we you know we do
pass that information as I said back to
the services to see if there's any
particular improvements that we can make
and equally in terms of any comments
that are about actually navigation on
our website for example we also um
review that with our web coordinators
who will make necessary changes as as
they can um undoubtedly we know that we
want to update our website and that is
part of our customer transformation
program moving forward and we did
undertake a substantial piece of work
over the summer periods to ensure that
our website was more accessible which
did um revolve around making sure that
content was written in plain English for
example could be read by screen readers
so some work that's already commenced
but still lots to do yeah I'm going to
I'm going to repeat a comment I've made
before user friendly and
intuitive uh but I do appreciate that
thank you very much thank you thanks
councilor thanks Sarah um and finally
councelor maber you have a
question yes thank you um C councelor
Osborne very kindly uh gave us a list of
the affordable housing um would
councelor Osborne very
kindly confirm the housing in
waldingfield road is this subb or is
this the
Chon
area it is subb it's it's it's very
border it's right sort of um it's more
it's a few yards into Jon John was it Oh
I thought it still subb there okay yeah
it's just coming up when you come up um
to it's on the um left hand side and
it's um just just over the border into
Jon thank
you okay all right thanks for that um
right um councelor Barrett your hand is
still up do you have another
question
no okay then um thanks everyone um I
think therefore that uh that's that's it
um as I said earlier this item is for
noting only so we'll now move on to the
next item which is item 11 paper BCA
2042 Community infrastructure Levy
expenditure program March
2021 and I'll now invite the cabinet
member for planning to introduce this
report so over to you councelor arthy
thank you chairman um I really don't
think it's necessary to go through how
the S framework operates um again
you are all familiar with that now um
and what you've got today are the four
latest bids that require your decision
um of course the S expenditure program
contains an update on progress on on
decisions on bid rounds 1 to six um
including December
2020 so the latest bids um and um these
are the ones for you to make decisions
on today firstly it's um b206 which is
Sudbury from the Strategic
infrastructure fund and we've already
spoken about this today it's the new H
fuel tank um there are two of these
being provided one in mids suffk and one
in babber at Chilton for our refuge
freighter and the total value of that
bid is £50,000
second one is
B25 which is in long mford and that's
from The Ring Fest ring fenced
infrastructure fund
it's an upgrade and Improvement of the
car park at the old school community
center in Long mford and there they'll
be able to provide 10 additional spaces
four disabled spaces and the
installation of new drainage and
lighting and on top of that they also
will provide three new electric vehicle
charging points the total value of that
bid is
22,000 2016 is in cockfield um and this
is a a bid that has arisen um out of the
inability to complete a previous bid
project um because of problems that were
were found with the bridge that they
were supposed to be putting a new
Surface on and when they took the old
surface off um they found that they
actually needed a new bridge so um the
first part of that project was completed
and paid out um and this is effectively
a second part a separate part um which
is for the works to the bridge and and
the total value of that bid is
$5,799
36 I'm not quite sure why cockfields one
goes to the Pence and none of the other
ones do but there we go um
B25 is in Lavenham um you may remember
that we awarded um money to uh a car
park in um Water Street which was the
old gas work site which was laam Paris
Council initiative on their own um and
then more recently we awarded money to
The Apprentice street car park and
toilet improvements which was a joint
initiative with baby District Council
who own um the car park and the toilets
um in The Apprentice street car park and
then this one is the other car park that
babber owns in laven which is in Church
Street um near the church and um beside
the coor pub and this project relates to
the upgrade of the existing toilet
building to provide new toilets and a
Parish Office um within the building
again it's owned by baby District
Council so it's a joint initiative um
but the toilets and car park are
operated by Lavan Paris Council um
similarly to the previous Apprentice
Street project uh the intention is to
make the toilets both covid-19 and
disability compliant and also to
significantly reduce the operating costs
of the facilities um in the toilet block
total value of that bid is £4
43,44 and I'm happy to propose the
recommendations which are at paragraph 1
sorry 3.1 and
3.2 um which is for the the bids I've
outlined in Sudbury long mford cockfield
and Lavenham um the second
recommendation is 3.2 um which is that
you note and endorse the S expenditure
program um for March
2021 thank you
chairman thank you thank you celor I may
I have a seconder for
this I will be happy to Second it
myself thank you right okay um opening
up for questions councelor Busby do you
have any
questions well I can wait for the debate
okay councelor Davis nothing for from me
thank you Council halt not at the moment
thank you councelor MC no nothing from
me councelor
Osborne no not at this moment thank you
Mr chairman and councelor
Parker no nothing for me chair thank you
do any other members of babber council
present have any questions on uh this
report councelor mcra not a question
chair but just a a reminder to members
um across the council that the S
expenditure framework is subject to a
regular annual review through overview
and scrutiny and that we have on every
occasion been satisfied that not only is
it flexible from the working party
working group that works on it but it is
it has been fit for purpose on every
occasion and yet it has changed
according to uh emerging circumstances
so so uh on that basis I think it's
reasonable to support the uh the results
that come out of the expenditure
framework uh that was just the
observation thank you very much thank
you
councelor okay then so if there no more
questions we'll we'll move into debate
um so council arthy do you have anything
else you wish to say in the in the
debate or um have you covered everything
I'll I'll just make one small additional
comment chairman if that's okay yeah and
that is um that thus far we haven't had
significant um calls on bab sill funds
um so most of the times that we're
sitting here looking at sill Awards um
we're looking perhaps at smallish
amounts you know they're in the tens of
thousands um but they're not um in the
millions however that's not likely to
continue forever um so whilst the the
demands on the fund have been far far
less than the value of the fund so far
um we've seen already in mid suffk that
there are um significant calls um when
you start to get things like School
extensions that are necessary as a
result of development and increased
School numbers um
so thus far it might seem as though you
know we're just sort of handing out
Awards to communities um but the as the
sill framework as the sill program rolls
on um there will as I'm sure you're
aware be significant calls on our s
funds yeah thank you yeah thank thanks
for pointing that out it is something
that um we do need to be mindful of as
as in the next year or two uh Council
Busby yeah I'm concerned with the the uh
Community infrastructure thresholds of
£775,000 or 75% of the total costs it
seems unfair to limit Community projects
to that kind of amount when we could be
spending hundreds of thousands on a
school if we raise money from a a
Housing Development it could be that the
money is desperately needed for an
expansion of open space or uh health
healthy activities things like that um
and that's just as important as
providing School places I would have
thought it seems strange therefore that
we limit that uh those projects to
75,000 it could affect it's certainly
going to affect cable and it could
affect uh Sudbury with the Bell View
project
perhaps yeah I mean you you've got to
remember that we're talking about
Community projects here um and in the
early days of um the S framework we
accepted that um we were collecting
money um and that in the early years
that might be used to address uh an
infrastructure deficit if you like in
some of our communities so um that's the
sort of example if you remember we had
um Preston St Mary Village Hall come to
us we had a few Village Hall
applications um as sill moves forward
you have to accept the purpose behind
sill which is to provide the necessary
infrastructure for the development
that's taking place and that's that's
where the big demands will come but
having said that I mean I think the fact
that we we've retained an element of um
support for our communities in regard to
infrastructure is a good thing and um
I'm helping the s team put together um a
revised scheme for Preston and Mary
Village Hall um where they were unable
to complete the project and it's been
clear that there is additional funding
that can be sought elsewhere so it was
never really Our intention that
Community projects would be funded
100% by a seal contribution
um but I accept that thus far it it
seems um perhaps um a little bit
unnecessary to have that type of a cap
on when we appear to have far more money
in our s pot um than we're being asked
to hand out at the moment but I'm that
will change and our framework has to be
fit for the future so it has to be you
know we have to look at what's coming
our way and and adjust the framework
accordingly but that's good to hear
because I mean for instance in C Mar we
targeted to have something like 750 new
houses in cable and it would not sit
well with the residents of Cal if 99% of
the money raised from those sill
developments or the developments that
produce the sill went to fund things
elsewhere when we're desperately in need
of things within cable but uh which
would come under the Community banner
and therefore only qualify for £75,000
which is a drop in the ocean to the
millions that 7 750 houses will
raise there won't there won't be
Community projects that are looking for
millions of pounds I wouldn't have
thought um sure there'll be requirements
of that sort of level but we're talking
about Community projects here and you've
got to remember that the community
receives via the Paris Council it
receives its neighborhood sill um so
what we have seen with a lot of these
bids if you've studied um how the bid is
made up um that 75% of the cost may come
from from bab's Sil poot um a lot of the
remainder certainly in the in the case
of cockfield and laven um has come from
neighborhood sale that the parish have
got so it's only the it's only the 75%
or
75,000 um that we restrict on Baba's
element so that's what you're being
asked to determine the total value of
the project of course as you can see is
is a lot more um I have got some figures
here if you want to know them I'll just
give you an example that you say that
there are unlikely to be projects that
are going to cost million pound millions
of pounds in fact C has got a project
targeted CH cost three and a half
million pound which is a new community
Hub uh 3G pitch and a muger um now we
expect quite a bit of that to come from
funding we hope from the Football
Association but we were almost depending
on on a sizable Chunk from sill £775,000
won't put a dent in that project it will
make it almost very difficult to start
okay but I mean I'm not it depends on
the facilities so it's not just who is
is putting the scheme together it's what
you're actually providing um so the best
thing that I can say is have a word with
Christine and Joe in the s team um and
they they will be able to advise you
about which elements of it um might be
able to be funded um from from where
where um so you know we offer the sill
inquiry service there's no charge for
that um it's part of the service that
the sill team um offer and I I would
just say that if you think you've got
projects that might need support um and
might result in a s bid just as early as
possible open open a conversation with
with Joe and Christine in the team um
and they'll they'll help you out with
what might be fundable and how we have
and they're being helpful thank you very
much good and remember that green
infrastructure doesn't have um the 75%
or 75,000 cap on it oh really thank you
for that okay you're worth your waiting
gold okay and um is is that uh cable
project is it listed in the
infrastructure delivery plan because um
that will provide a higher threshold
won't it councelor arthy
yeah I think it's listed in ours I'm not
certain whether it's in the jlp one
we'll have to look at that open a
conversation with the SE team and that
you know they'll be able to help right
thanks okay then uh councilor Davis um
yeah just to to weigh in a little bit on
that one um yeah CLI is absolutely right
that yeah the sill offers a proportion
of funding towards Community uh
infrastructure projects but the um our
community's team have just amazing
grants officers who can pull money out
of all sorts of areas so you that's very
much an Avenue that should be explored
as well you know because they deal a lot
with places like the football Foundation
the fa various other um governing bodies
when you're talking of the the sport and
infrastructure hadly are looking to do
something similar and um we've had a
meeting with them and Chris and and Roy
are are supporting um in what they're
doing as well and and so there are lots
of different ways of doing it and and it
worries me when you say oh you know it
won't get it started I think you you
will get these things started and Sil
can quite often be the uh um the bit of
cream and the cherry on the top as well
so that there's lots of lots of money
out there you know and and please you
know as he says go to Christine and the
s team but also come to us at
communities CU we we've got a lot of
depth and knowledge and experience in
finding money for you and that's to all
councelor not not just to councelor
Busby thank you coun right and moving on
to um Council Hall I'm conscious of the
fact that we we're kind of digressing a
bit from the uh particular items that we
need to approve so um I would like to
focus the debate on on those um if
anyone has any comments on on those so
councel Hal you're next no questions
thank you right okay uh councilor Mo
excuse me Council
mvi
no questions thank
you councilor Osborne no Mr chairman not
from me at this moment sorry we're in
debate now we we've had
questions nothing to say at this point
Mr chairman thank you okay then
councilor Parker uh no no everything's
good I've thoroughly read the bids and
um I'm certainly supportive of them
haven't got any any issues at all thank
you no well I'm uh I'm certainly in
support of of these uh bids um they all
seem to be um uh just the sorts of
things that um we we should be
supporting and uh a good
um uh selection of different types of
things and in different communities so
um I think therefore um unless there are
any other comments from members of the
cabinet we will move to the electronic
vote okay um so I'll ask the governor's
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please thank you chair members if you
could go into your modgv app the vote
for this item is now in
progress councelor Ary can I take your
vote please my vote is for thank
you
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for thank you very much CLA right
moving on to item 12 paper BCA 2041
solar multifunction carport
microgeneration now this report is in
two parts part one is in the is the
public part of the report part two the
appendices is confidential
so I'll now invite the cabinet member
for the environment to introduce the
report so over to you councelor
mvi thank you very much
chairman right way back the council's
carbon reduction management plan commits
that we will explore opportunities for
low carbon energy generation with a view
to minimizing our Reliance on the grid
one example is solar Farms another one
solar car ports battery
storage this will include options for
Council owned land buildings and other
investment
opportunities further the council
strategic Asset Management plan 2020 to
2025 references that the council will
support the delivery of low energy
projects through proactive asset review
of the council owned Estates or other
investment
opportunities this project proposal
delivers on both in late summer 2020 the
economy and regeneration team
successfully bid for Central governments
getting building fund program to gain
match funding for up to 50% of the
capital Grant it's capped at 400,000 per
site but it must be delivered by March
2022 to access the funding this award
makes a considerable difference to
viability and deliverability for the
council and gives a timely opportunity
for the council to demonstrate its local
place leadership in respect of Economic
and environmental ambition and I've
mentioned that earlier on this evening
the project is a learning pilot using
Council Brownfield site assets and if
successful could be deployed by the
council and businesses Developers
elsewhere in the district to make a
cumulative localized energy
microgeneration impact towards district
and County Ambitions of carbon reduction
by
2030 specialist advice has been sought
on the business case and optimal system
to support existing and future uses in
and around the site with an objective of
energy costs and carbon sa savings at
the council owned Leisure centers and
full recovery of the investment within
the life cycle of the pro of the
Project's benefits this project is now
linking into further recent Grant
success of 1.4 million for both mids and
babber to deliver further heat
decarbonization now that means air
source heat pumps insulation and further
solar um
energy but at our Leisure Center Center
estate and it's in and it's reflected in
the recommendations of this report I
commend the report and its
recommendations to
cabinet thank you councilor MVC may I
have a seconder
please well I will happily oh councelor
Busby you second I will thank you very
much thank you thank you right okay then
um so firstly
questions from cabinet members Council
Ary do you have any
questions uh no thank you chairman no
councelor Busby no thanks councelor
Davis no I'm good
thanks councelor Holtz fine thank you
chair councelor
MV no I've not I don't have a question
for course you
that's the trouble reading down a list I
I usually do skip the the right one at
the right time but uh councel Osborne no
thank you Mr chairman the report gives
me all the information I need to know at
this point thank you what is s yeah
thank you councelor Parker no questions
chair right okay then do any other bab
council members present have any
questions at this
stage in which case I will move into the
debate part so councilor arthy do you
have any questions or do you wish to
contribute to the debate no only to
fully support it chairman I think it's a
fantastic idea yeah okay councilor bosby
you couldn't have said it better
myself councelor Davis yeah
dto councelor halt uh fully endorse my
fellow councilor's
comments councelor
Osborne thank you Mr chair chman uh no I
think it's a great a big step forward um
so well done to all concerned because I
think it is good to thank those people
where thanks are due thank you councelor
Parker nothing further to add
chair thank you councilors uh no well
this this is um a great step forward for
for babber to to be able to do this um
and it's great that we've been able to
get some match funding um it is a pilot
um no doubt there'll be lessons that we
can learn from from this but um uh I'm
I'm very pleased that we're able to do
this in the um uh the Station Road car
park in in subury and uh I hope it will
be a great success not just in terms of
providing uh clean electricity for for
people to uh recharge their vehicles but
also to be able to feed into the king
fisher Leisure Center itself now there
is an option for members to go into
private session to discuss the
appendices um does anyone wish to do
that um we have the financial
information in the appendices it is um
very
clear um but
uh if if you don't wish to we can go
straight to the vote but um please
indicate if if you wish to go into
confidential session uh Council your
hands up uh it was just to say thank I
thought um
this proposal is evidence of how working
together can achieve wonderful things
and it's the economy and regeneration as
well as the environmental team so well
done to all for working together and
pulling
together councilor
arthy
um yes I I don't think um we need to go
um into confidential session for me to
say this um it relates to um the the
funding but um it's really just a a a
comment that as far as I'm aware no
inquiry was made with regard to um
whether sill might have been able to
contribute to this um I I take my hat
off to the successful application to get
specific Government funding um but I I
do worry a little bit that sometimes um
we internally miss a a trick um it
happened with the first of the um EV
Char points that we put in where we paid
for them out of our own budgets when
they could have been um funded through S
and as far as I'm aware it may be that
an inquiry was made but I don't think it
was um and it may be that it wouldn't
have been eligible because it's um it's
a a government funded scheme um and
there there are sort of various
restrictions but having said that
without asking the question you don't
know the answer do you so um um that's
my only comment
really okay um thank you for that
um did you require sort of a response or
an answer on on that was it just um an
observation well um I I don't know if
there's anybody who can help with that I
mean I presume there's some supporting
officers here and they F Fiona's here
Fiona Fiona do you know whether um you
asked the S
question um we do actually have uh the
project manager Lee here as well and so
he may well have asked the question that
the point I was going to make is the way
the reports worded is um we now need to
do some further investigations in in
light of the additional funding that's
been secured for through the public
sector decarbonization fund and that
will lead us to have other conversations
about how we can better improve the
business case so I don't think the uh
doors closed on any conversation around
additional
funding thanks K actually I I've got um
a follow-up um uh question I guess sort
of question on on the funding and we we
we've been successful in the getting
building fund um match funding and mids
suffk have been similarly successful for
for um a a sister project in in Stow
Market if we hadn't put in a bid
together would we have independently
been successful or was it the fact that
we worked together on this um helped
very much in getting that getting
building
fund support I don't I don't know that I
could answer that something fun might
want to answer um I mean obviously
collaboration is is is good in the world
of funding but for this specific one I'm
afraid I don't know without asking the
funer yeah Fair Fair Point yeah okay but
I I I just just leave that thought
hanging amongst um members um okay thank
you for that Fiona right so uh CL can we
move to the electronic vote please um uh
because I don't believe anyone wishes to
go to confidential session um nobody
else has made a comment about that so um
we will take take the vote
now thank you
chair members if you
can go to your modup app the vote is now
in
progress
councilor Ary can I take your vote
please yes my vote is for thank you
thank you chair that's eight votes for
thank you thank you very much thanks
right okay um we're now about to move
into the last item on the agenda um does
anyone want to quick break before we do
that or are you happy to
continue I'd like a break chairman right
okay I thought that would be the case um
it's now 10 7 um is a break of 10
minutes sufficient for everyone sounds
great yes thank you we will uh start
again at 20 7 then
so
okay welcome back everyone and we're now
uh on to the final item of tonight's
agenda which is item 16 paper BCA 2044
regeneration of the Belleview site in
Sudbury now before I ask the cabinet
member for the economy to open this I
just like to say cabinet members we have
a complicated matter to debate and a
very important decision to make to make
as with the previous item this report is
also in two parts part one is the report
and appendices a b and c and is public
part two is appendix D which contains
ident identification of the biders
financial information and the bid
scoring Matrix this is confidential and
cannot be discussed in Open
Session I proposing to deal with this
report in the following order following
the introduction and then questions from
counselors I would like to conduct the
debate in two parts firstly we will
debate the object C we have received
then we will debate the substantive
matter substantive matter that is which
of the six bids we have received if any
we should approve as indicated in the
recommendations of paragraph 3 point
paragraph
three I would like to discuss as much of
this as we can in Open Session without
having to exclude the public but we will
enter into private session if necessary
for questions and debate on the
commercially sensitive information
contained in the bids as detailed in the
confidential append D before finally
returning to open session for final
comments and the
vote so uh having said all of that oh I
just also would like to introduce uh a
couple of additional um attendees uh we
have from the shared Revenue partnership
um Sam Samuel anwe and also Alan Taylor
so um I will now pass over to councelor
Holt to introduce the paper thank you
chair um what we have today in front of
us is the paper for the Regeneration of
the Belleview site in
subury I think as all members will know
and uh those are viewing the site itself
has a long history going back to
2013 when the council agreed to dispose
of the site during the years leading up
to now we've had various schemes come
forward the latest one prior to this was
for the
hotel um due to the pandemic uh the
partner in that subsequently pulled out
and left us with the site again as it is
today um at that point decision was made
uh re BW to bring it into the vision
work for
suby alongside the Hamilton Road quter
um and the market Hill um improvements
and also obviously with the Hamilton
Road the bus station
moving um part of that was to as it's a
vision of sub to bring the B you start
within that Vision it seemed logical to
work together with one group uh at
babber all sort of organizing the lot
structuring the lot Thinking Beyond um
just a single project but collectively
bringing them all
together and on that basis um we brought
in the team that have been working on
Hamilton Road to look at Belleview and I
think it's important to remember we had
an engagement event back in January 20
of which I think it was about 800 people
attended in
subur and there was a lot of positive
feedback on all the vision items that
were on show at that time including
Belle view um some people didn't like a
hotel some people wanted an open
Frontage there was various different uh
opinions uh come out of that and what
we've done is drawn on those comments
and what we've got today in front of us
I believe is a scheme that uh reflects
what certainly the people that attended
that engagement event at St Peters
wanted to see the future of Bellevue
Park and how they perceive uh saw it and
it was up to us to try and deliver on
what those people who voiced their
opinions uh wanted to
see obviously there's a
compromise um we can't give everyone
what they want but what we've got today
I think is is a project and a scheme
that represents what compromise is all
about we've managed to get an entrance
uh into this scheme whereas previously
we hadn't we've got a cafe and new
toilets proposed which previously we
hadn't um we had several um opinions
about the house about being demolished
about it being locally listed Etc and
what you've got today if we do go down
to uh look at the bids is that all those
bidders have actually uh said it or
their intentions are to retain the house
and I think it's important again that um
that's come
out what we did after that it went
through the Steering group um the sub
Steering group and there was three
options presented there and one was
certainly favored which had the park
entrance in it and I think again it's
been poorly documented how the Steering
group actually took
the
decision it's it's a steer I I shouldn't
have used the word decision it's a steer
but the Steering group which is
represented by sub town uh council is
represented from Town Council um Chamber
of Commerce business group suffet County
Council um the St peters's uh
organization and gainsb house also have
Representatives on it
and I just feel it's important I get
across that that Steering group did give
a steer on this
and it is representative I believe of of
organizations within
sub and I don't think it's it's easy
when you have a project like this with
so many different opinions to come up
with a scheme that I hope you see today
that um will I believe have a lot of
support amongst many people around subur
I know the Town Council have voiced
their concern and they seem to be going
down the road of of wishing to have a
massive wide open uh front entrance um
but that's come late in the day from
them um certainly um through the years
we've had nothing like that before and I
feel a little bit disappointed there but
I'm not going to dwell on any more about
this because I think it's so important
that we've got so many members here who
want to speak on this I'm sure and it is
a difficult decision because it is an
important part of subury and as much as
some people might think that we don't
care about subury as as a baby cabinet
um I do and I know other members do and
this is our chance to show that we care
for suby by delivering and it's all
about delivering for Sub sub may have
had a lot of uh conversations in the
past but I feel it's time we delivered
something and I believe
this opportunity to choose a scheme out
of the six biders is an important step
for suby to show that we mean business
and that we do hold sub close to our
hearts and the Regeneration of sub is so
important not only to the people of sub
and the surrounding Villages but also to
baber as a whole and that's what I
really want to say at the moment thank
Youk thank you councelor halt um I'd be
happy to uh second this um
now before I move to questions I just
wish to draw everyone's attention to the
agenda supplement and this contains a
report prepared for subur Town Council
by one of the biders there are a number
of points raised in this including some
that are covered in the list of
objections we'll be looking at and we
should address them as far as possible
however we have not had the opportunity
to respond to and challenge this report
directly with its
authors okay then so opening up for
questions uh councilor arthy do you have
any
questions um chairman I I have just one
um and it concerns um the
boundary that's indicated on the
plan um and it appears to run across the
Terrace um at the back of Belleview
house and as you know I've asked this
question before but I'm I'm just
thinking that the terrorists
most properly if the house is being
retained should go with the house and I
just wondered if there's a an answer as
to um if that could still be
achieved thank you Castle Hol did you
want to pick up on
that uh the red line for the one two3
notice was as defined but I'm certainly
we'll bring Fiona in to see if got she's
got any comment on that because um this
historically is the red
line yes and the red line that Michael
just referred to actually is the
boundary of the house uh it defines the
difference between the house and the
park um and that footpath is is actually
within the park as defined by public
open space so that's why the red line
was where it
was thanks is that answer your question
councelor
Ary well um not not really because I'm
just thinking that any reuse of Bellevue
house and as you've said already all of
the proposals um indicate that they
would want to retain the building it
seems to me that it offers a fairly
uncomfortable um boundary now obviously
we would continue to retain ownership of
the park um so we would um own
effectively half of the
Terrace and I just wondered whether we
ought to have some sort of
um confirmation that we we can offer as
to where we see the future of of that
Terrace because I mean obviously there's
a um it's almost like a shared wall
isn't it um at the front of the the
window there um and then as I say it's
it it I'm not quite sure why the line
was drawn there it seems a bit of an
arbitrary place to put it you would have
thought it went either um one side of
the Terrace or the other um and of
course the Terrace has steps at the end
um and then the paths that allow people
to go from the park um up the steps and
onto the Terrace of the house I believe
it's fion alluded to it it is where the
open space starts and stops so um that's
where the red line is I think this sort
of thing to be be honest C is is almost
a planning issue at some point um in the
future because all the biders have
certainly known and been aware where the
red line is and once and if a plan
application was to come forward then
those sort of things will be dealt with
planning I mean the fact that boundary
is is the boundary is no different to to
a house or anything else our own houses
or whatever that is the
boundary okay and I I presume that the
owners of the house would have certain
rights wouldn't they um to be able to um
maintain the house so they' have rights
to scaffolding and things like that to
do Works to the
house um I'm happy to come in there yeah
I mean all of those negotiations would
happen uh post a decision being made on
the recommended bidder um it would be
part of the legal
agreement thanks okay
thanks okay uh councelor Busby do you
have any questions well it's interesting
that you started the the debate on this
um I looked at the the proposals for all
of the biders this morning and the two
preferred bids two and three if you
study their Red Line it's considerably
outside the the area that was offered
for sale in fact uh the people that are
going to convert the house have said
that they need 5 MERS from the house
which will include the Terrace and the
bank and that runs the whole length of
the
site uh plus there's an extra bit at the
top and there's an extra bit at the
bottom I think this disqualifies them
from participating in this bid process
because they haven't complied with with
the
offer I think you'll find their offer is
unless fer uh contradicts me their offer
is for the defined red line on the
section 123 bid
you can you get the plan up you'll see
that it's significantly outside what
that is I can come in there Dave uh a
number of the biders have put proposals
in which involve pieces of land that
were not within the red line um because
it's an informal tender um we're not St
we don't have to stick to quite the same
rigid uh rules that we would have to
with a formal tender so that would have
to be in with any of the bidders that
were chosen if if they had included land
outside of the red line we would have to
take that as part of the negotiation
going forward but that is not our land
to negotiate it's public open space it's
part of the
park it's a significant part of the park
well it is our it's it is our land um
but you're right it is public open space
and we would have to therefore raise
another offer for sale I presume if we
wanted to if he wanted to put that in
with those other
bids but but as Fiona has said um those
aren't the only two bids bids that have
gone outside of the red line and so the
same would apply for for all of the bids
um whether they are uh commercial or
Community bids that have gone outside
the red line that the same rules would
apply yeah I guess so yeah I mean we we
so we we can't disqualify one and not
all of them well we should disqualify
those that don't comply with the with
the rules of the offers for
bids we can't decide to AC them we
haven't got the right to do that it's
public open space we can't just hand it
over um I I agree uh that we can't just
hand it over um but because it's an
informal bid process if you were to go
with uh one of the bidders who had asked
for additional land that would have to
be negotiation once you'd made your
decision to go with that
bidder I think also when you when you're
discussing the bid you also take that
into account as well to be perfectly
honest with you
well we we'll pick this up in the debate
I think um we're still in question mode
the moment but it's um you're right
councelor halt I think when we look at
the individual bids um we will pick that
up then um right okay councelor Davis do
you have any questions no questions from
me thank
you okay um so councelor
malvi thank you chairman um the
situation over Open Spaces concerns me a
little bit and naturally um I couldn't
support anything that removed um and
substantially reduced um open space
without something
else mitigating it
200% that's all a comment thank you okay
so no question at this stage
question okay councelor Osborne any
questions yeah I do I take it we're
looking at the objections aren't we as
part of this question yeah yeah
questions on any aspect of the report
okay um confidential side of it sorry
there's an
echo can you hear me John yes yeah yeah
well on the governance part of the
objections on uh objection 12 I think
it's listed as it's about the open space
deficit or or correctly inferring
Surplus asset can you just can you just
clarify for me uh Fiona or Michael that
there is actually sufficient open space
as required in law I think it's so much
open space per population count and um
have has that figure taken into
consideration uh the projected growth in
subur over the next 10 years please
thank you oh and and also sorry M Mr
chairman I have another question 15 um
is about um lack of community and Town
Council engagement now my understanding
is as a counselor there's been a great
deal of consultation over the years on
this so if Fiona orain councelor HK
could just clarify that there actually
has been a high level of consultation
and engagement thank you thank you
Council OS and Council hul would you
like to pick up on both of those Fiona
do you want to pick the first one
up um actually I I think Lee's with us
um I think it would be better if Lee
answered that one if that's okay if Le
if Lee's still with
us yes um certainly so um yeah
objections refer to to open space um the
local plan shows the area of this of the
site which is um currently in the 2006
open space
um plan as open space um the report the
um there's a 2019 report that's been
referenced and is in the bundle for
members to consider as part of the
objections um relating to some more
upto-date um reporting that was done as
part of the joint local plan process so
that has been attached as part of
members consideration there um we are
aware and we have referenced it in the
objection um summary that um there is
some areas that have not been included
within the sort of town area which would
be considered open space which the 2019
report doesn't evidence um it will
really be down to to members to look at
that um and and we up the um potential
um loss of the open space in the context
of the the potential benefits of the
disposal um and also there has been
reprovision of some of that public um
recreation use to other areas of the
town for example the swimming facilities
in the skate park and the new um M use
gaming area so um so yeah that those
references have been made and put into
the report and members will need to
balance those references uh as part of
the wider considerations for the report
as
mentioned um just following up on that
Lee is it true to say that the 2019
report when when um suggesting an open
space deficit did not take into account
the extensive um Meadows along the river
the Fri Meadow the water Meadows yes
there there's some areas which the
public realm team have fed back um that
which have been excluded or not
designated in their opinion correctly in
that report that is not a strategy
document that is just to inform um the
local plan development um so again it's
it's about weighing up all these issues
including as we said the reprovision of
of amenities elsewhere in the town um
but yeah there is um although that
report exists it's not a strategy
document and it is deficient according
to our own public realm team thank you
Lee uh councilor hul did you want to
pick up on the um uh
Council engagement
consultation um what we've done is is
all the way through since this has I've
been chair of the Steering group which
is goes back 2019 is have Town
councilors sitting on the steering group
and this is where the opportunity is
come for the Town Council to gather the
information and partake in in discussion
and um and conversation about the plans
that were coming forward for b viw um at
one time there was four Town Council
sitting on that Steering group there are
now three um now I can't help if they do
not go back and Report what's going on
to the four Town Council but that is the
opportunity and that has been the
process for the Town Council involvement
through the Steering group um as I say
if for some reason that is failing then
I suggest the Town Council look at the
members on that Steering
group thank you coun
H oh okay then um moving on questions uh
next um councelor Parker final questions
from you yeah thank you chair and I'm
not I'm not sure if I'm jumping ahead
here or not but I've I've got a question
around the uh the recommendation
actually um as shown in the report um at
item 3.5 which INF fairness is in part
two um but nonetheless um I'm going to
ask it whether it's now or later so we
might you know if it's all right with
you we'll do it now but 3.5 does state
that should the preferred bid withdraw
or otherwise not proceed on the terms uh
that um delicated Authority be given to
the assistant director for economy to
proceed and negotiate with an
alternative bidder and I am uh I'm I'm
deeply uncomfortable with that chair um
I I have to say I think that any
decision as significant as this must
come back it must be a cabinet decision
so I don't know what the process is for
uh for for amending that and indeed I'd
have to um I'd have to win the the
backing of of my fellow counselors but
um I think that's yeah I'm deeply
uncomfortable with with that uh uh thank
you Council Parker yeah um I think um
one or two of us have expressed concerns
about that uh when we come back for um
final comments just prior to the vote um
we will go through the recommendations
all five of them just to check that the
wording of each of them is as we would
wish if not we can make some changes at
that point um prior to going to the
vote is that um okay with you uh councel
Parker it is it is chair and also D
councel halt as as the owner of the
paper yeah I think it's a fair point
that Council park has raised and I think
it's something that has been voiced to
me by the members so um I'm more than
happy to do that yeah we'll um we'll
just go through those then um just prior
to the vote to make sure that we've got
the wording exactly right okay uh I'll
now open this up for other bab
counselors to ask ask questions so
please uh raise your hands councelor
Owen you are
first thank you ever so much for giving
me the chance to um ask some questions I
don't know if you can see me right right
I've got two questions um the first one
is um has there been any discussions
with any of the biders prior to the site
being marketed that's my first question
should I ask a second question as well
ask them both now and we'll take them
back yeah um why did the bids for the
house in November
2019 have to do a full presentation at
St
Peters in January
2020 as part of a community
consultation and yet there is no
requirement this time around and the
whole process now has been behind closed
doors where is the TR the where is the
open and transparency this gives all
counselors a bad
reputation
you okay thanks your questions and um
the the additional
um comment there at the end um I'm not
so sure that I necessarily agree with
with that last but we'll take the
questions so um councilor halt did you
want to take them directly or I'll I'll
pass them to well the first one I'll
certainly pass on if I may because uh as
for uh any of the biders having PRI
knowledge on I would say no but um I can
ask the owner if she's got any
information on
that um a number of the biders quite a
large number of the biders uh actually
bid previously so uh they were obviously
aware of the site um and uh so when the
when the marketing commenced um they got
back in touch so uh yeah there were I
can't remember how many out the six but
a large number of
of the uh of the six had previously
either been interested in the site or
had bid on the site so there has been
there have been previous discussions
with most of the parties actually or
certainly a large number of
them does that does that answer the
question yeah I I I think that does
thank you Fiona thanks thank you and and
the second question regarding um the uh
the presentations that well I want to
say presentation we had that um
exhibition in St Peters in January 2020
um where um the a number of the the
biders at that time around were invited
to um display what their their proposals
were yes they were and um what a
successful event it was but um when the
hotel negotiations broke down and
obviously the site become uh available
as such again um it wasn't certainly
considered that uh an engagement event
like that would be warranted um as the
actual red line site is still the same
um and obviously what we were looking at
was uh disposal of the site with with no
fixed um objective unlike the hotel
which was a a fixed objective and a
known um result um what we've got here
is is a disposal of the land and that is
open to bidders to put their bids in
which is what's happened so I don't see
how you could have necessarily a public
engagement or anything like that event
when all you're doing is selling off a
section of land for those biders to bid
and and bid what they want to do with
that site
afterwards thank you
councelor councelor Creswell thank you
chair just put myself out see me thank
you chair um what I was going to say
this is really to councelor Halt um what
I was told by people on the steering
committee that the papers they got for
the Steering group did not arrive till
possibly the night before or a very
short notice so when they went into the
Steering
group decision seem to be made before
before they actually got there so they
came
away actually come away quite confused
and then come back to the Town
Council and felt like they'd been
brought into something that they wasn't
particularly happy about that's the
impression I got about it Michael so I'm
just telling you the feelings which came
back to the town
hall than you do you have a question as
well um I'm happy to uh it was more a
comment about how how the people felt um
going to the steering committees getting
late notice or late papers and then
feeling
like everything was already out of their
power before they got to the meeting
okay thank you I come back on that
please um
certainly as far as the steering group's
concerned there are some commercially
sensitive papers there that will not be
broadcast uh in advance really at all so
that may well be the case that they're
referring to
but I think what you have to bear in
mind is counc Creswell that there's an
officer Group which is which precedes
the Steering group of which your town
Clark goes to and other
officers um which information is
sometimes shared and that's another way
that the Town Council can gain this
information um or or build the
information up prior to a seran group
meeting but we're never going to get
away from the fact that if there's
commercially sensitive information it
will not be shared broadly and that will
always be the case as I say there was no
decision made before the Steering group
The Steering group is there to give a
steer and that's exactly what it does
and and it's down to all the members who
attend the Steering group to have the
confidence and the Comfort to give those
steers at that group and report back to
their bodies that they represent whether
it be the Chamber of Commerce or
business people or the Town Council
that's what it's about and I do find it
annoying that these things keep coming
up again and again and again the steing
group works and is the way it's designed
to work and the Town Council just have
to get used to
it thank you councilor
SES hi thank you chair sorry you can't
see me hunting my head um mine's more
about um and this is from um somebody in
my ward is asked me to ask the question
giving the big push that baby District
Council has committed to for climate
change including biodiversity policy and
a clear focus and commitment
to all environmental
concerns um of they and needs for the
future um and the open space
requirements have will these be
considered please thank you
yes thank you yes they
will yeah I mean um we've been very
mindful of of that um and have built in
uh certainly with with the the the
all-encompassing plan for for the park
um a commitment to ensuring biodiversity
within the park um uh there are things
that we want to do to enhance what there
is there already um the new park
entrance that we're we're proposing will
um certainly help towards that and and
also be energy efficient um so um we we
are doing our level best to to meet our
biodiversity our environmental uh
commitments because um the those are
commitments that uh we're not just
paying lip service to them we we truly
believe that they are necessary for the
viability and and um the well-being of
all of our communities going forward so
if I can just add there um in the
telegraph last last week um they were
talking about I think it was a type of
panthia shrub and I think um 2 m of this
shrub takes up as much carbon emissions
from 500 of a car so hopefully they
would be um various types of parantha
but that's something that could take
away um some of the um you know awful
stuff that's in the atmosphere thank you
and I believe that's quite a prickly
Bush as well so it act as a good
security screen yes yes not easy to
handle but it's
useful U coun Moi did you want to come
in on on that in response to councelor
a um no other than biodiversity and
climate change action plan are here to
stay and they will crank up even faster
um because there's more legislation
coming down the wire and if we
want to get to 2030 and not get flooded
out then we're going to have to really
crank it up so it's here to stay yeah
thank you counselor um if there are no
other uh questions from councilors
present I do have a question from
councilor Lindsay um who's unable to be
present so he's asked me to read it out
on his
behalf so Council Lindsay's question is
why would we want to spend £750,000 on a
lovely new entrance with visibility from
King Street which is a really good idea
when we are then going to allow
developers to build on a very sign
significant remaining part of the public
open space which overlooks that entrance
and therefore diminishes the value of
the open space surely it is better to go
with the option to refurbish Bellevue
house into residences and await grants
Etc to allow us to make the former
swimming pool area safe and attractive
for the public a wildlife area Springs
to mind and would cost very little
councilor H would you like to respond or
comment in any way on on that question I
I have some uh comments myself but I
think I'd uh leave it to you Council
Lindsay is is very complimentary in his
in his approval and uh
of the entrance that we're proposing but
I do understand that uh he wants a a
full width entrance yes and that we
should be waiting basically for funding
to come along on the uh money tree that
never seems to appear so um I would
question the uh deliverability of that
um and the costs involved in that has
anyone really has he done his homework
and researched to find out how much
money's involved I think we've got a a
reasonable idea from the work we we've
had to do to get to the end entrance
where we are today as such that we're
proposing it's a lot of money an awful
lot of money and um as I said before in
my introduction I think what we're
proposing is a good compromise in that
we have an entrance to a park we're
going to spend money in the park we've
committed to putting up to 100% of any
money gained from the side of this land
into the park into the into the park for
the people of sub to enjoy into the park
to make it a better place for all young
families and children to play this is
what we're intending to do this is why
we are doing it to make sub a better
place thank you councelor
halt right okay um we'll now move into
debate as I said we're going to conduct
the debate in two parts firstly um the
objections that we have received and and
uh there are I think it was 32 some of
them are quite
extensive um and objection 27 actually
if if any members wanted to focus um
does seem to be the most comprehensive
and and it covers many of the um the
issues raised by other objectors but um
to open this debate councelor arthy do
you have any comments on uh the
objections um well no I've got a
question for you actually I'm not quite
sure what you're doing here I've Prov
questions into debate but if you want to
go back to questions I'm happy to no no
no um you're doing two sessions of
debate one on the objections one on the
objections and the other on the um the
bids okay now I haven't I haven't got
anything to say on the objections thank
you right okay councilor
Busby well I need to say I think there's
a lot of validity in the objections and
I think we need to take them into
account when we make our
decision yep councilor
Davis um no nothing more to add to that
okay um next will be councelor
malvi nothing to no no nothing at this
moment councelor Osborne not at this
particular Mo moment no councelor
Parker um well just to say that we
obviously we're going to need there's
some very detailed information in some
of these uh objections and we are going
to need to uh to take it into account um
we are going to need to thrash out for
example the
uh the the loss of um of open space um
because that's a genuine concern for for
for an awful lot of people we are we are
losing open space and that that's
recorded in in the objections and we're
going to need to address it but I
suspect that this is going to be a very
long debate um uh as the night goes on
chair thank you okay um right well the I
I I do understand that and I'm expecting
a long debate um but uh I I did really
want to as far as possible go through
the objections um and uh get some sense
as to how members feel about them before
moving on to the the actual bids
themselves because there certainly there
things that um have been raised
regarding the validity of the section
123 disposal process um and uh I I think
we we need to um uh to talk about that
um that there's also comments about um
uh what some more specific details and
the 123 about um the actual disposal of
of the land itself and and and best
price or best value
um the the other thing that I think is
uh uh councilor arthy um something you
could clarify and that's regarding the
the position on sill on this because one
of the bids is the uh is a community bid
and I believe um they are interested in
the potential of of sill funding um now
we did uh when talking about the sill uh
expenditure item earlier um reference
the uh 775,000 limit
um
sorry there's
an okay that seems we gone um so
councelor Ary are are you able to um
comment in in any way about the the
ability of a sill application to support
that Community
bid well um I'm I'm not the person that
judges the applications ultimately the
cabinet is um but obviously the
assessment is done by the Seal team I'm
not aware that there's been a s inquiry
um but that doesn't mean there hasn't
been one um but I'm not aware that
there's been one um Community bids would
be governed by the framework um and yes
they would be um they would have a
maximum of 75,000 pounds and or 70
75% um but as far as I'm aware there's
there's actually been no inquiry is is
that the question you're asking um it
should there be an inquiry um what
basically um and do you know what kind
of advice or or um limits um advice we'd
be able to give or or whether there are
limits on on what they'd be able to do
with with sill um bearing in mind as you
said earlier that um
we we do have uh that £75,000 limit we
also have um uh the potential that our s
pot may not um be sufficient as it
stands for um what we know is going to
come down the line for for major
infrastructure in the way of um uh
School additions um doctor surgeries
that sort of thing yeah I me I I think
you'd have to you'd have to have
something a lot more specific um it it
has to be the provision of essential
infrastructure so you can't just sort of
make something up
um so I you know I don't know what
specifically the sill infrastructure
project would would be that that
somebody would be bidding for um and I
don't know whether it would have the
support of the Town Council um it's
you're asking me a question about
something that that's not at all
specific okay yeah all um fair enough um
I was probably uh being unfair in in
what I was trying to ask but um I was
just picking up on a point that had been
made in in one of the objections um I I
do have something I wish to um raise
with uh one of other of the legal
Representatives we have here and that is
the suggestion that um we have uh being
a breach of statutory Duty um regarding
disposal under the section 123 notice
um uh is one or other the the legal
Representatives here able to provide
some some guidance on that or Fiona um
I'm happy to start off then defer it to
Sam or or Alan um the legal uh process
requires that the uh Redline redlined
area is published for a minimum of two
weeks uh we actually published it for
three weeks um so uh as far as we have
secured legal advice we are entirely
appropriate in the uh legal sense in
terms of uh advertising that one two3
notice but but perhaps Sam or Alan would
like to come in on that on that
point yes um this is Sam here you're
right funa in saying that um this is a
statutory provision the one 12 3 2A is a
statutary provision for uh this open
space uh sale of open spaces and the um
as we know the council is a trustee of
um of um um
of the of the land you know comprising
the open space so therefore um section
one when when we are you have to
advertise as you as youve said you know
ad advertisement has to be done and in
two in two cons consecutive weeks and um
so by virtue of um uh
section one uh 164 of Public Act um 1985
and then section 10 of open space act
1906 where where we we we selling the
land under Section 234 so sorry 1 123 2A
of Local Government Act
1972 then section 23 21
123b you know
um uh where the land land is sold under
1 123 a then 1 23b give um give the land
provides that the land is now free from
U any trust arising solely by by this uh
uh what do you call it um the um the
sections of the public house and the
open space act that I I just mentioned
so in all if
one the the question is that you know if
where it's um U the these have been
advertised and um and
and with um it's been advertised and
therefore we we cannot you know the
point is there there is no no um the the
councel can go ahead and you know sell
sell those those open space
land thank you thanks Allan did you have
anything further to add to that um no
I'd just like to agree with um Fiona and
Sam I believe the council um did use
they used fre week which was more than
the the time necessary and specified um
I believe that we've done we've done
what we should have under the section
129 okay thank you um i' got some hands
up from members of the cabinet here
councelor
Parker yeah all right um chair so let
let's let's get into um let's get into
these objections then so um with no
disrespect to um to to the objections as
as a whole there is one that my eyes
have fallen on particularly and that is
representation number 27 um because it
it it seems to have some technical Merit
and um uh has has been extremely well
drafted so um there there are some very
uh Salient points in there and the first
one of is is of the Surplus land
requirement um and in that L the
objector has um
charged that uh this this is an area of
U of of land um and by disposing of this
land by getting rid of this land we
actually create a deficit uh which uh is
being charged is not only against the
national planning policy framework but
is also uh against our own um uh
policies uh Etc so it's shown on page
214 of uh of the report and onwards it's
a very it's a very long uh report but
I'd be interested to get Fiona's views
um on on the charge that's being made
there with regards to the Surplus land
requirement
please yeah I'm happy to come in uh
there so uh the definition of public
open space is very difficult to Define
um it's defined in a number of ways um
the most uh obvious way is how we Define
it in our local plan in our current
local plan uh we have only a very small
area of the red uh the land edged red
defined as public open
space by provision of the new park
entrance we're actually roviding more
public open space if if you take into
account what's in our current local plan
however um previous uh land used for uh
public Leisure for example could could
be deemed isn't necessarily but could be
deemed to also be public open space and
um I think that's why it's important
that cabinets take into account that if
you were minded to to think of the old
swimming pool site
or rather the part we're selling as
public open space um it should be noted
that you have rovided those public uses
elsewhere both in Belleview Park but
also in the swimming pool uh that was
built to replace this swimming pool um
back in I think it was I'm not quite
sure when when it was actually built off
the top of my head but um so that's the
first thing the second point that I just
need to make cabinet aware of is that
Lee mentioned it earlier there is a
study it's not a uh Council approved
strategy but there was a study that was
carried out in
2019 which did look at public open space
um which uh seeks to include an
additional area in the Red redlined Land
uh in um in any future um public open
space design designation that has been
taken account of in our emerging local
plan and that includes the house um and
I think that the car parking area to the
rear of the house um so although it's
not local plan at the moment it is in
our emerging local plan now that would
in theory uh if uh that public open
space designation is adopted in the new
local plan in theory uh there could be
deemed to be a deficit however it
doesn't take into account the new area
that we're creating the new Park area
which is a a sizable chunk of the
existing swimming pool site um and also
it doesn't take into account uh the the
area of open space that were emitted
from um the report which is as John
mentioned earlier The Meadows which is
obviously a sizable amount of uh Green
Space in Sudbury so sorry that's a bit
of a long-winded answer Lee but that's
uh public open space is quite difficult
to actually Define and pin down no thank
you f longwinded is what's required so
thank
you right okay thank you for that um I'm
just uh counc Hulk you're next on the
list yeah I was just going to say um
there's a lot of um very good um
objections um with with a lot of content
and I just want to make sure that
everyone listening is aware that the
council has not move forward with this
project without seeking legal advice and
we are confident in our position that um
we can move forward with um this project
on the advice that we have been given so
there are some objectives that have got
as councel Parker some quite detailed um
objections written but certainly Our
advice that we have SE um from our legal
uh department and and is that we can
proceed and we are all okay to do so I
just want to make sure that that point
gets across we just not ignoring it
thank thank you thanks councelor
Osborne right thank you Mr chairman um I
don't know if it's just me and I
apologize if it is but um we just heard
from Sam sorry I didn't catch his
surname um giv um a um description on
where we've been with the object the the
s123 and 2 a and 2B uh I got a little
bit confused on it I I don't think it
was explained very well could could
somebody explain it perhaps a little bit
clearer because we have got a lot of
people listening in as well and if I
couldn't understand what he was saying
um then I'm sure and the contents of of
what he was saying not how he was saying
it of course I'm sure the members of the
public and other councilors listening in
uh have a problem with understanding it
as well so could it be re-explained
please
Fiona uh yes I I I can't claim to go
into the the the different uh lines of
legislation but in in very basic terms
um and this is by the way in the public
report if anyone um has got the time to
to look it up we have outlined that but
essentially um the council is not
allowed to sell public open space unless
it publishes a notice telling the public
that it wishes to do so um the public
have the right to object and those
objections must be considered um and uh
obviously carry they carry a number at
some weight so in any decision made in
terms of selling there has to be uh the
balance assumed between uh the
objections and the benefits from selling
the site in terms of best value or best
consideration so the the section two3
notice um the relevant section of
section one two3 notice uh relates
specifically to the ability to sell uh a
site that has an area of public open
space in it and we're obliged to MK to
advertise that notice for a minimum of
two weeks um we actually advertised it
for three weeks um so we have been told
by our lawyers that we have satisfied
that criteria and that
objection
thank you f that is much clearer thank
you very
much coun
Mani thank you Mr chairman it was just
to say that Fiona um explained Open
Spaces very well as well as other things
a lot of people automatically assume
that an open space is green it is not
necessarily green you can have a great
big Plaza Piaza whatever you square um
and that is an open space um and you
mitigate the biodiversity impact by
ensuring that you put plants that
benefit thank you thanks right um before
we go on um what I need to do because
we're at um 8:15 um and uh we need to
formally extend this meeting Beyond 8:30
um because there's no doubt that it will
go beyond
that um so I'm proposing that we do
extend beyond 8:30 may I have a seconder
please Council thank you um now I don't
have to take a formal vote on this all I
need to do is to get General consensus
from the cabinet um unless anyone has
any objections I will assume that we all
uh consent to uh this meeting
extending okay um then uh we will then
be able to proceed Beyond 8:30 and to
its conclusion whenever that will be
this evening right um thanks everyone um
I've I've just got a looking at um
objections again a comment
regarding um in again in objection 27
there's there's a statement saying that
the council is legally bound to sell the
land for not less than the best price
under Section two3 um and babber have
therefore um based on the facts
presented not met this condition and and
there are a number of points um but in
terms of best price isn't it actually
best consideration where um price is not
the only Criterion which is why in in
our
assessment um we have got a number of
non price-based um criteria that we we
are assessing the bids against um so uh
in in that respect I believe we are
compliant with Section 123 can uh can
anyone Fiona can you give confirmation
on
that yeah I I'll hand over to Lee if
that's okay John sure
yeah Lee are you
there oh lee seems to I don't know if
he's dropped off the call okay I can
answer it um yes generally speaking best
uh it's best consideration that the
council has to um sell or best value so
uh that we can uh take into account
other factors such as economic
regeneration
Etc thank you and and and that's why um
in the report um in oh gosh what
paragraph is it right at the
beginning
[Music]
um I'm got go the beginning of the
report sorry about that
uh we've got the uh assessment criteria
at um
4 where is it 4.15 that's no not 4.15
where is it
the
4 22 that's right um so we've got the
quality elements the four quality
elements there um of a comprehensive
development plan for the whole site um
development with enable regeneration
evidence that the bid has the financial
capacity track record and the evidence
of time scales and uh required to
deliver so um we're taking those into
account and and uh each of those in
addition to price has has um a scoring
weitting which the um uh the evaluation
Matrix will um has been based on so um
uh we have covered that so so moving on
are there any other points that anyone
wishes to make about the um uh the
objections it's probably worth if if you
wish to to to look at appendix C1 which
is the summary sheet um and that has
been sent to to members of the cabinet
as as a separate um paper so that um you
can look at that um separately from from
the bulk of the report um because we've
got essentially um the categories of uh
uh disposal conflicting with other
policies Etc we have um discussed that
um marketing deficiencies I think
Council has um has covered those um uh
and and the governance procedures as
well we' picked up on on one or two of
those are there any of the others listed
there that any Cabinet member wishes to
to comment on um there are 19 separate
points there councilor Parker uh well I
I was just going to say um chair it's
going to be staing the obvious but
obviously a number of the objections do
still make reference to uh the fact that
people don't want to see a a hotel on
the site or or otherwise the the
property at at Belleview house is being
demolished and and of course neither of
those things are occurring and I just
think it's worth stating that publicly
that although obviously thank you thanks
and and also um the comments that we're
working with a preferred bidder that
that is not true either we we don't have
a preferred bidder we have six um
potential bids and uh we will be
choosing one of those um and we we don't
clearly
um they they have been scored and rated
but we don't have a preference in as
much as we haven't been in in uh uh uh
separate and and um privileged
discussions with a a single bit bidder
out of those
six um so okay then um just moving on
just closing that down so are we happy
that we've addressed the uh the
principal objection
members of the cabinet do you feel that
we can move on to discuss the
bids um chairman if you if you want an
answer to that I I think the answer is
yes we have um I must Adit I didn't know
that you were going to sort of have a
separate debate on um on the objections
but I think the point is that we've seen
them we've read them we've studied them
um and it's a little bit like um when
you consider a planning application um
you you see the objections you read them
and you you take them all on board um
that doesn't mean that we have to have a
debate to say whether we agree with them
or not um but I've certain I've
certainly read them all um and inwardly
digested them
all yeah if I can say something John I
think C's Clive's right but I think it
was very important that from a legal
point of view that we covered off all
the legal aspects because if there was
something in there that was was
fundamentally correct and our advice was
not to proceed then that is what we
would have to do uh but we've got the
legal advice um that we are able to
proceed and I think Clyde's right there
are some issues in there that would come
forward with particular bids possibly
that you would debate at the time you
were discussing those bids but I think
it was so important that we got the the
legal situation explored viewed and so
the public can hear that we we haven't
just dismissed this we have gone out
sought confirmation of our position and
we are where we are today and we are in
a position to
proceed yeah uh I think that's right not
only have have we been very diligent in
doing that um I I do believe that um we
have been as open and um uh uh inclusive
as as we can um we we've had a
consultation period for this particular
disposal as indeed we have for all of
our plans going back many years um with
with this particular site um we've had
uh consultations we've had um uh public
meetings we had a public meeting I
remember in the uh the room upstairs at
the the town hall back in 2017 where we
started uh putting forward our our plans
for for sbur including uh the the uh
possibility then of a hotel at bellw uh
we had the the exhibition in St Peters
um we we do our level best to to engage
with the public and and get feedback um
it
is I guess to certain extent um
understandable but a shame that um when
we do get feedback like last year like
last January um yes we had about 800 at
the exhibition and we had about that
number of of actual paper um feedback
forms uh return to us but that is only a
tiny percentage of the population of of
not just the town itself but the greater
sub area um it would be so much better
to to get um a much um uh more uh
widespread view of of what people want
but I guess they're expecting us to um
as as we are elected um councilors to to
lead and and to um show them what what
we are coming up with and um and uh to
give them ideas and um uh and to
reassure them that we have the best
interests of the town as residents at
heart councilor
Osborne thank you Mr chairman yeah I I
do I do understand um those concerns
raised in those objections that we've
got before us tonight but I am happy
with the legal advice otherwise there's
no point in us getting legal advice if
we're you know if we're not going to
follow it through so I'm happy with the
legal advice and I'm certainly happy to
now proceed to the discussion of the the
bids yeah thank you um Emily you've got
your hand up
thank you chair I just wondered if it
would be useful for me to give the
cabinet a view of my uh opinion as
monitoring officer of the procedure
that's been
followed yep um so we've we've got the
section in the report section seven
which is the legal advice which is very
clear you've got detail in the report of
how those uh legal requirements have um
been followed you've heard from the
legal advisers this evening that they
are satisfied that the um
the process required by the legislation
has been followed correctly and I think
in all of the comments made by
councilors this evening we've had a
reference made to the objections which
to me indicates that those objections
have been properly considered by all
members of the cabinet um therefore in
my view the procedure has been properly
followed and I think that you uh are
able to move to recommendation 3.1 and
therefore uh start your debate on the
bids themselves thank you chair right
okay um I I suggesting we take
recommendation 3.1 now um to enable us
to continue or or still wait until the
end to take
that you don't need to take the the
recommendation 3.1 now to to continue
your debate um but if you um would like
to do that to draw a line under that
section um that's equally uh
acceptable okay uh I I think that
probably would would be a good idea to
be honest um let's let's go to
recommendation 3.1 now
then counc yeah yeah if if I can
formally um um recommend that I think
you seconded it earli but I didn't
actually formally um ask for recommend
or ask for approval so okay if that can
be noted yes certainly thank you
councelor halt right I'll ask the
governance officer then to uh conduct
the electronic vote for recommendation
3.
one um do you do you want me to read it
out for everyone it might be a good idea
at this stage and that is that having
fully fully considered the objections to
the disposal notice given pursuant to
section 1 two3 brackets 2A of the Local
Government Act
1972 the disposal of the site shown in
appendix a for best consideration
reasonably achievable be
approved okay so um may we have the
electronic vote open
please thank you chair yes the vote is
now in progress thank
you councelor Ary can I ask for your
vote please yes for thank you thank you
just waiting for one
vote thank you that's eight votes for
chair thank you CLA right okay we're now
moving to debating the individual bids
themselves so we have six bids um which
you are all aware of now um we need to
be careful if you uh do wish to debate
the uh the um confidential nature of
these then we will go into private
session but um if we can keep the debate
at the moment to the um the
non-confidential aspects and then we'll
make a decision on on going to private
section uh session later so councilor
arthy thank you chairman yeah my
comments are actually more General
debate um and um the first thing I want
to do is kind of agree with what
councelor Hol said in his introduction
and and it's also in in the report um in
2.1 um and that is that we doing nothing
is not an
option and I've I've been a counselor
for 30 years and I remember things
happening in Sudbury I remember um
ballington Bridge um I remember the
Betty Cocker close um you know the the
go back far enough for the ging street
car park um and and there will be
objections to what you're proposing to
do but if you actually just step
backwards and say oh well there's an
objection so we mustn't do anything you
end up with a period where you do
absolutely
nothing I went to the exhibition at St
Peters um I think it was two days and I
went both days um I spoke to people
there and there was a lot of encouraging
comments about the fact that we as a
council had finally come up with a
vision for Sudbury that we were actually
going to to do something that we had a
plan to do something in subury town
center I was really encouraged by that
the only thing that I heard negative
comments about um was the hotel and
particularly the design of the hotel and
that is now behind
us regarding Belleview house I think the
the the part of the objections that that
I found most interesting was the um the
opposition to the demolition of the
house
so we did a whole load of um work on um
what could or couldn't be done with the
house um there was the application for
listing which um failed um the house is
not protect protected and I think that
ought to be absolutely clear whilst
we've got proposals from all of the
biders to retain the
house we cannot guarantee that um it may
be that at sometime in the future um it
it gets listed I mean it's certainly a
building of of local interest but if we
sell the house um we we have no control
over that and I could give you an
example of when something very similar
happened in laven when I drove past one
day and there were there were guys
knocking down Lavenham railway station
and there was absolutely nothing that we
could do about that it was just outside
the conservation area and it wasn't
listed and if you own a building you can
demolish it
so the the protection afforded is not
guaranteed however I think from our
point of view the fact that we've
actually got offers from people all of
whom are interested in retaining the
structure of the house I think is is
good news so if you go back to sb's
vision and what we can do um and what we
presented in January of last year it
seems to me that everything that we had
in that vision and the the only slight
fly in the ointment of the hotel it
seems to me that we're we're actually
now starting to achieve something and I
don't see the sale of bellw house is
negative at all I agree with what
Michael said this is actually moving
forward this is part of the vision for
Sudbury in the next five years and if we
can achieve this I think that the people
of Sudbury will thank us I know they
might not say that now but in five years
time if we achieve everything that we're
trying to achieve I think the center of
Sudbury will be a better place and I
hope that people will then say it was
very very difficult
but we're now living in a much nicer
environment in the Town Center so I I
compliment Michael because he's he's
sort of um he's ended up with a
portfolio that that that brought with it
huge problems and it's it's actually
quite Brave of him I mean he's a he's a
he's subb boy um and you know it's it's
not easy um to to propose changes that
solicit Sometimes some some fairly angry
responses
but hats off to council Hol he's he's
come up with it he's he's about to
deliver the goods um and well done thank
you councelor arthy yeah and and center
of subre um will be better for it but
also more importantly will be fit for um
the the future the rest of the 21st
century it it can't stay the way it is
um that's that's the way uh to decline
and um we don't want that for the town
we want all towns have got to change um
uh because the the nature of the urban
environment is is changing rapidly so um
I I'm I truly believe that our vision
for sub will put it in a very good
position for the future councelor Busby
uh you're next on the list thanks yeah I
think we'd all agree with
that uh doing nothing isn't an option um
f if I could ask you to bring
up the retirement home which is our
second attachment I think a second bid
and go to
the plan that they've
got
um I we'll need to check with Lee I
think we might be straying into the
confidential uh
area oh because it it's got the name of
the people on
it Lee do you want to pick that up
you're on
mute sorry um yeah I think this would be
part of the confidential item um unless
the monitoring officer has got a view on
that c can
you councelor Busby are you able to
continue uh with your train of thought
without go um going into that we can
obviously move into the confidential
session later but um well no I think
it's significant that we s we're looking
at the plan when we discuss it well we
can do that in confidential session yeah
okay well in that case unfortunately I
think we need to go into it okay well um
can we just go through uh um uh the rest
of the councilors now and then we'll
move into confidential session in a
short while are you are you willing to
yes hold off moment thank you thanks
councelor
Davis yeah thank you yeah it goes
without saying we can't do nothing and
we're not doing um nothing and uh
Council H has has put together um a very
very good paper very complex very
difficult paper um with a lot of time
and effort from the officers and and I I
I have no doubt
that that you know whatever we end up
with um and it certainly won't be
something hideous like highrise flats or
anything D like that you know it will
open the park up it will be to the
benefit of sub and hopefully to the rest
of babber as well um because obviously
is for the whole of babber although
we're focusing on subur and it's
important that we as a district council
do focus on the vision of Sudbury um and
and I think this is this is part of that
um and yeah I won't be tempted to go
into any of the individual bids as such
um but yeah certainly let let's let's
move forward and get things
done in terms of um the non-confidential
aspects um uh of the bids do you have
anything to say on on any of them at
this stage um no I I think I've read all
the different things and I do have one
or two sort of um ideas but I certainly
wouldn't say that I'm ready to throw my
hat into any particular one just yet
okay thank you um councel HT do you wish
to say anything at this stage yeah I I
thank cly for his comments but I I'm not
a suby boy and if we leave that
unchallenged I'm afraid that may be uh
spread wider than this forum um I'm a
glamood boy actually but I am one that
uh visited bellw Park and enjoyed its uh
its uh facilities as a young boy and uh
swam in the pool as as well so I'm I'm
certainly one that grew up around subur
and used the park so um but I'm a glimps
with boy and proud of it thank
Youk thank you Castle
mvi thank you yes I'd like to commend
councelor Holt and Fiona DL and the team
um because I think uh
the unexpected position with the hotel
and the previous plans um the rug was
pulled out from everybody's feet cuz
nobody anticipated covid and I think
you've turned it round very quickly into
a positive um and yes we cannot you
don't stand still people think that you
things stay as they are they don't they
regress and I think this is a chance for
Sudbury to move forward so well done
everyone thank you thank you councelor
Osborne yeah uh thank you Mr chairman
yeah I I also ATT ended that engagement
event that was held in St Peters and
there was some really great positive
comments coming out from it which was
really you know as a counselor it was
really encouraging but the message that
that was given to me very clear from
most of the people that I spoke to there
was just get it done you know let's move
forward get it done the other one was
keep the house retain the house if at
all possible and the other one was open
up the entrance to the park um so that
you could view it from from King Street
so I think you know thinking of the the
the six bids we've got before us today
um I think we can achieve this with one
you know with a selection from one of
those bids so we need to look at them to
make sure that they deliver on that
there are challenges coming forward for
the town there are many challenges for
uh everywhere but you know for our
Market towns and we we actually only
have one Park in subury you know I often
go to Woodbridge because that's where my
grandchildren are though I haven't been
there for 12 months um they've got three
parks and they're are similar makeup to
subur so it's the only part we've got
and we really need to enhance it you
know our volunteers have done their real
best as a public realm but it used to be
the jewel in sub's Crown crown and it's
it it's not any longer you know even
with volunteers doing as much work as
they possibly can it's it's just not and
this is a a real opportunity
to bring it back to the jewel in in
sub's Crown um there is sub Town Council
have spent a lot of time on putting
their preferences together in a document
which U members of the cabinet will be
aware of but I I'd rather refer to that
later on when we actually move into the
discussion on the bids themselves in
regards to the bids um
obviously I'm looking forward to a
healthy discussion on all six of the
bids um but the things that I want to
say will actually be part of the private
and confidential discussion and and not
in the public
domain thank you Mr chairman thanks
Council OS uh councelor
Parker yeah well I'm interested to note
um chair that there weren't really many
questions there at all um L lots of
statements so um I'll I'll ask a
question um so of the bids that are
before us none of them proposed to uh to
demolish um bvw house which is which is
excellent and um and that I think is one
of the over riding desires of everybody
in subur but is it true to say that in
the event that the successful bidder
whoever that may be in the event that
successful bidder finds that actually
the house is um uh is not viable to uh
to convert or to save um that actually
sub might lose its house anyway somebody
got any comments on that I would I
comment on that John yeah go ahead y i I
think you're absolutely right councelor
Parker and that's what councelor Arthur
was too earlier um we are sunning the
land the house is on the land the land
the house then becomes the it what goes
into the ownership of of a new land
owner and they can do as they see fit
with the land um there's no guarantees
so yes you are right to put it bluntly
um it is encouraging however that all
the biders wish to retain the house but
I do take your point and it is
absolutely spot
on can I come back on that chair yes
yeah
you know I just uh those of us that are
are close to subury live in subury uh
work in subury um understand the depth
of feeling and emotion that runs uh with
with with B View and I'm just concerned
that when we talk about um you know this
being a compromise it's a compromise for
who um it's it's I think the perception
will be that it's a compromise for the
uh cabinet of baby District Council
because by its very definition a
compromise uh is a position where all
the interested parties move from their
original position uh and and come to a
position that everybody can agree on and
and the fact of the matter is here is
that it is B District Council uh cabinet
that is that is making this decision uh
and so for the good people of suby and
the people who are so emotionally
invested in in the decision that we're
going to take tonight this isn't a
compromise um it's uh it could be
perceived as actually as a Hobson's
choice um and I just think it's
important that um that we say that if
I'm you know if we if we're making
statements um I'll just start with that
but um I shall certainly enjoy the uh
the debate with regards to the um the
bids in private session thank you if I
can come back on that please yes of
course compromise is an
entrance Cafe toilets improved Park
facilities that's your compromise you
got an entrance a cafe new toilet the
house you say is very important to many
people in suby is it
a few vocal people possibly sub Society
think it's very important but I wonder
how many of the people in residents in
sub and surrounding area really think
the house is important I don't know we
always seem to have a minority that that
come forward and and pick particular
points up um but there is compromise
councilor Parker without a doubt and if
you can't see it I'm sorry but that is a
compromise
there John may I come in briefly yes
certainly f sorry I just think it's
important to clarify that uh a number of
the bids that we have received are are
related to refurbishing the house and
turning it into residential
accommodation um if if any of those bids
are taken forward then obviously um
people buying a residential house or
residential flat will either want it on
a freeold or a long leas hold basis so I
don't think I think that there are a
number of the bidders that are proposing
to put residential accommod back in that
house yeah just I just wanted to clarify
that point yeah thanks the and that
probably uh is uh the saving Factor
because at least for residential
conversion the the house as it stands uh
is is a more viable proposition um uh
other other potential uses are more
problematic um it is no longer suitable
as as an office building couldn't be
converted to offices in in any form at
all and other potential public uses
would be very difficult as well but um
uh residential is is a far easier um uh
potential use of the house uh councilor
Busby youve got a hand
up yeah could we put a covenant on the
house to stop people uh knocking it
down don't think you can do that to be
honest but that's a planning matter
really it's not not something for us
this evening quite honestly um uh that
would have to um be the for the planning
committee to to decide um when when
they're assessing any application well
surely it's a legal thing as well I Me
Maybe em can answer that I I can answer
that um you could uh you could put
Covenant on it it might put off some of
the purchases um but actually uh if you
went with one of the uh one of the bids
that was for retaining the house as
residential uh then it's very unlikely
it would be demolished anyway at any
point in the future because it will have
a value as a as a residential house
yeah but surely if they if we impose
conditions on it so that they can't
extend into the park and they have to
stick with the original Red Line they
may decide that it's not viable as a
residential place and decide to do
something about it I knock it
down um the uh a number of the bids are
on a conditional basis so the sale only
completes once the planning process has
been successful uh so all that would
happen prior to planning is that
contracts would exchange pending a
successful planning application if
planning couldn't be secured then those
deals wouldn't go
ahead some of the bids actually state
that there can be no covenants or at
least one big stat there can be no
Covenant um if you um yes some some may
do um but uh you know as I say if it's
for residential purposes it's unlikely
provided planning secured that that
building would be knocked down
anyway yeah okay thank you councelor
Osborne yeah thanks Mr chairman um it's
uh I think it's very unlikely that that
they would want to demolish the house
but if they did I was going to actually
say that it would be it would be subject
to plan in in any case I'm sure wouldn't
it to to have to demolish would be would
need planning permission um and if I can
just refer back to the document that the
subur Town Council put together they
they also State um to quote as far as
possible the house should be maintained
but if this is not possible any
development should be sensitive to and
not extend the current building Mass so
I think going back to alluding to what
councelor halter said I think the people
you know realized it would be nice to
retain the house if at all possible but
if you can't then you can't as long as
you still continue to improve that
particular site and the Park area
itself yeah thank you
councelor okay um I think we we'll
probably move into or or take a vote to
move into confidential session soon but
I just wanted to to say a couple of
things myself
um I I think it should be made clear to
to all of those who accuse us of not
listening and ignoring their wishes that
this simply isn't true I do that many of
them know it uh it's quite frustrating
to have to keep repeating this but there
is a difference between listening and
taking on board views which we of course
are happy to do indeed have done and
exceeding to demands which we cannot do
we do understand the desire for a new
entrance to the park from the town
center and we have now developed a
scheme that is attractive and provides
new Cafe and toilet facilities it's not
quite what some demand and it is a
compromise as Council holder stated but
it has the Merit of actually being
deliverable unlike like other schemes as
councilor Parker intimated others do
need to Mo move towards us in this
compromise it will however need to be
funded and that is why we undertook the
recent marketing exercise which is
option C in paragraph 2.1 of the report
and why we are here today to evaluate
that and decide which bid to approve now
I know that there have been comments
that um oh it's going to be another ugly
building opposite the former tax office
site well nobody knows that there's
there's no design yet um nobody knows
what's going to be uh constructed there
there um where it's precisely going to
sit all of these are matters um to be uh
decided later as part of a planning
application I think that um as as other
members have said we we've got something
here that potentially uh will make the
town very proud and provide a
rejuvenated Park area
so excuse me having said
that we do need to talk um specifically
about th those individual bids and and
um we can't do that without considering
the uh the confidential nature of of
some of the uh material we've got to
discuss and so I want to move to a
resolution to exclude the public um
which uh actually includes the press as
well so to consider whether pursuant to
part one of schedule 12 The Local
Government Act 1972 the public should be
excluded from the meeting for the
business specified Below on the grounds
that if the public were present during
this item it is likely that there would
be the disclosure to them of exempt
information as indicated against the
item the author of the report proposed
to be considered in part two of the
agenda is satisfied that the public
interest in maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information so do I have
a
proposal I'll propose it chair and
second coun Arthur your hand is up is
that you
seconding I'll second well I I'm I'm
happy to Second chairman my hand was
actually up for a different purpose
though and that was just to offer my
apologies to councelor Holt for adding
to his credits by calling him a a subury
boy um I do apologize for that um I'm
sure that the people of glemsford are
proud of him and were he to be a Sudbury
boy I'm sure the people of Sudbury would
be proud of him as well he works in
Sudbury of course does yeah okay well
well thank you for that um so um I'll
now ask the governor's officer to
conduct the vote to go into a private
session but uh I just wanted to
reiterate for those watching on YouTube
that we will be back for final comments
and the vote but um I can't guarantee
how long it will take for us to to come
back but um hopefully not not too long
um so um Can Can we uh please have the
electronic vote go go into private
session thank you
chair the vote is now in
progress thank
you councilor Arie can I take your vote
please my vote is for thank you thank
you
just waiting for one
vote thank you chair that's eight votes
for that's unanimous great thanks Claire
okay can we have the the live stream
Switched Off
please
thank you uh welcome back everyone um we
are now on the home straight and um just
prior to the the vote I'm going to ask
cabinet members if they would like to
make any final comments so councelor
arthy um no I don't think so chairman
thank you councelor
Busby tempted but no councelor Davis no
thank you councelor Holt no thank you
councelor mvi no thank you councelor
Osborne no thank you councelor
Parker
no well thank you members of the cabinet
um we've had a very extensive debate on
this we we've been going two and a half
hours which I think is right that we
we've done that um uh to do this item
Justice um because we we know how
controversial it is how important it is
to the people of SBR and indeed to the
people of of the
wi
indeed indeed the the um important to
the wider District as well it isn't just
sbur um and and we are not just here um
as sbur councilors we do have to look at
what's best for the whole of the
district and and and indeed sb's future
um uh is is important to the district is
our largest town and we want to see it
Thrive
um right we've now uh voted on uh
recommendation 3.1 earlier so now we're
going to vote on the remaining
recommendations but before we do um
Council Hulk did you want to make any
proposed changes to any of the
recommendations yeah if I could please
um I propose that preferred recommended
proposal bid a b in paragraph
4.24 um if we can insert that in there
in recommendation 3.2 yeah
y okay thank you are there any other
changes that you you wish to
make um I don't think so sir I'm not
sure 3 3.5 3.5 oh 3.5 yeah sorry yeah
thanks for remind 3.5 there if we can
remove that entirely because if um the
big if the bid fails as such and it
comes back um it will come back to
cabinet and that's a little bit vague in
that one so it says about the director
so assistant director but if we can
remove that totally so if anything
happens it automatically comes back to
Cabinet yeah thank you CLA do you have
uh those
changes thank you chair um Mandy is now
making those changes in the vote yeah I
would just wait for her to confirm that
we are ready to
go thank
you are you going to take them one by
one chair or are you going to do them
all in one go all in one go three Point
2 3 and
four okay thank you chair uh Mandy has
just made that Amendment
now
so your vote should now be in
progress It's taking a while to
respond is everybody having that yeah
okay now now it's come back it's come
back
now yeah got
it is it now responding for everybody
not for me okay I think it might be best
I think um as we've been going for so
long modov is uh having a few issues so
if I could revert to a roll call just to
ensure that
everybody um we can get everybody's vote
so councelor Ary for the
proposal you councelor Busby
against councelor Davis for
councilor Holt for councelor
melisi for councel Osborne for councilor
Parker against and councelor Ward
for chair that's six votes for and two
against therefore it's
carried thank you very much CLA thank
you and thank you members of the cabinet
thank you other counselors uh present U
for your
contributions um uh I hope that I I know
that some of you may be disappointed
with with the result but I hope you feel
that we we did the subject Justice um we
did have a a long debate um you I did
give you all an opportunity to air your
views um and all I can say is uh let's
look forward and and work together to to
really make Belleview part the the duel
and sub's Crown um which I know it will
be the the entrance that we're proposing
is is going to be great and the people
of subri will will will learn to love it
I'm sure um and we will have the means
to finance it which is important thing
these things do cost money um babber is
not flush with money and um sometimes we
we have to um make decisions that that
are compromises but I hope that um the
Town Council and other bodies in in the
town do do recognize that we we are
doing things in good faith for the
benefit of the
town so uh I'd like to thank everyone um
we can now all go off and grab something
to eat before uh getting an early night
um we might even have a glass or two of
wine I guess but the the date and time
of the next meeting is scheduled for
Monday the 10th of May at 9:30 and there
is no cabinet meeting next month we will
be in the moratorium period because of
the uh County Council and police and
crime commissioner elections so um oh
and thank you to all of the officers for
staying the course um yeah uh it's it's
been very uh your your contributions and
support has been absolutely um necessary
for for this and um uh I I know on
behalf of the cabinet um we we all
really appreciate what you've been able
to do for us this
evening thank you
everyone all
I